[Music]
foreign
oh no
no no
[Music]
foreign
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls in addition to stunning
geography Norway is home to the greatest
chess player who has ever lived Magnus
Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
more young stars are trying to follow in
his footsteps laude Beck Abdul sotorov
and kukesh donoraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana two more long-time
Headliners seek to take their next turn
Atop A major tournament Wesley so and
shakuria Mami yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
hello and welcome to the Grand stage
that is Norway chess it's right here in
Stavanger with the world's best chess
players are getting ready to take those
daring risks perhaps those stunning
sacrifices and of course play some
Fighting Chess I'm Ivanka houska and it
is a great pleasure to be here calling
all the action in the Stavanger Studio
alongside the legendary Grand Master
Judith poga and of course commentator
and Grand Master extraordinaire David
Howell oh and Judith yesterday we had a
really intense day of Blitz were there
any standout moments for you oh there
were a lot of moments I can say I had
Great Entertaining
um strangely enough maybe but I had one
specific game which I recall very
vividly which was very impressive it was
a magnus's game against Nakamura where
he had a great opening we thought he's
going to be just smashing Nakamura then
it was a turn over there and suddenly he
was getting into a lost position and
then with some magic real magic with his
King
but of course there are a lot of very
interesting moments we had yesterday
yeah certainly and after that day of
action David the players are now playing
the first day of the classical event how
are they feeling yeah I think some of
the players will still be recovering
from yesterday it was a real wake-up
call Judith you mentioned Magnus Carlson
hikaranakamura both of them struggling
both of them in the second half of the
blitz event and now it's classical of
course they've got to start again
they've got a completely roof rash and
reset but it's not going to be easy for
either of them it's certainly not going
to be easy because take a look at the
field that we have lined up in no HS it
is the creme de La Creme the top of the
top and there we can see there is Magnus
Carlson now he's been at Norway Champion
five times and then we have Fabiana
Carana who won the tournament in 2018
other big names alireza frusia Hikaru
Nakamura Anish giri Wesley so shakuria
mamajov nordebec Abdul soturf who won
the blitz yesterday Arya antari and go
cash and you have your eye on any
special player dude it
oh that's a tough one to make right well
I want to see the youngsters definitely
very much how they are going to be Excel
how much uh gokish we recover and I want
to see also Magnus how he's going to
recover
uh it's I think from day to day I will
have different kind of favorites to pick
on and uh David do you have any
favorites I'm sorry you guys yeah I'm
putting you on the spot yeah tough
question I'm going to be watching out
for two players firstly Fabiano caruana
who uh won a very strong tournament
recently in Romania and uh now starts
off against Magnus casting in round one
but also Abdul satorov he won the chess
kid Cup last week fantastic performance
beating Fabiano in the final and
yesterday winning the blitz he might be
one of the dark horses for the whole
event and uh David as you mentioned
yesterday nordebec abdustov did win the
blitz with an impressive six points out
of nine but rather shockingly Magnus
Carlsen didn't actually place in the top
five he finished seventh and AV reports
a svera caught up with him after the
event
how would you summarize the date today
among this yeah I'm pretty pretty bad I
mean
considering the level of my play I
should not be dissatisfied with my score
really uh because like most of the games
I was just
I couldn't really calculate it all I was
just guessing so it's it's in that sense
it's okay but obviously it's
you know the level of uh level plays
it's pretty bad can we expect uh more
normal Magnus Carlson tomorrow
yeah I hope to get some normal sleep and
then hopefully uh
would be uh it would be nice good luck
thank you
and Magnus Carlsen might not be too
happy in that interview but he certainly
can be happy about these stats I mean
take a look at it he's number one in the
feedout world ranking he's been there
for a long time five-time Norway chess
winner five-time theater world champion
as well as the reigning four-time world
rapid champion and a reigning sixth term
World Blitz champion and guys what did
you think about that interview and will
that have impacted well his performers
will will have impacted today's games
potentially well you could see
definitely that he was really unhappy
about what was going on yesterday in his
performance and he didn't look like in a
very good shape yesterday it seems he
pointed out that a good sleep will help
probably and I think it's very important
for him to make a good start because
he's famous for that that he can make a
slow start and then he recovers and
beats everybody and goes to the top seed
but I think it will be very important
now because he's not that young any
anymore he's not a world champion
anymore he's number one so there are a
lot of things changing in his life and I
think it also means that he has to have
or it will be a little bit more
important to start well yeah I think
that's the key point should at the start
and it doesn't help Magnus that uh due
to his performance in the blitz
yesterday he starts off today against
Fabiano caruana tomorrow against Wesley
so then game three against uh Hikaru
Nakamura that is running the gauntlets
if he can survive those and maybe emerge
with positive scores from those first
three days he'll be the favorite for the
tournament but in such a stacked field
if he starts badly I do fear for Magnus
it could be a tournament to forget oh
there's certainly words of warning from
David and well what a beautiful lineup
we have with the world's best players so
let's take a look at our round one
pairings and they will be coming up soon
and we can see Fabiana caruana will face
off against Magnus Carlson alireza
farouza meets goo cash
will probably play his explosive style
against Ari antari and then we have
Nordic Abdul sitarov playing against
Anish giri and Wesley so and hikara
Nakamura in the All-American Showdown
and dude it which matchups do you have
your eye on
well definitely I want to see alireza
and gokash that's very important matchup
but my eye will be strongly on Fabiano
they have such a past uh the world
championship match they play they played
countless Blitz rapid classical game and
of course it will be very interesting to
see in what form they are so you know
round one is always kind of a warm-up
but they are ready to bite and David
what about you Ivanka with sport for
Choice that's the problem man uh I
mentioned him a bit earlier Abdul
satoroff I want to see his game I think
if he gets off to a good start against
Anish giri then he might be one of the
favorites for the tournament the
All-American match up as well between
Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura
historically tends to end up in draws In
classical games but that's the beauty of
the unique format in Norwich every day
has a winner certainly and I also feel
like a kid in a candy shop and I really
can't choose between them and I'm sorry
for having asked you guys the question
but I'm also pretty excited between the
All-American showdown between uh Wesley
so and Hikaru Nakamura for me you know
that one might get personal because in
their last encounter it was Hikaru that
was Victorious so well it will be a day
of excitement and fighting at chess
that's one thing that can be guaranteed
and I think the clocks are going to
start ticking down and we are going to
to
a lot of action ahead and first of all
of course the thing about Norway chess
is the tournament format it is unique
it's never really been done anywhere
else in the world and this makes it
super exciting and it's a 10 player
single round robin
120 minutes for the first 40 moves and
then
10 seconds will be added after every
move after move 40 and of course if the
if there is a draw then Armageddon will
break the tie and there is no draw
offers allowed before move 30 and this
is such a unique format it really you
know you don't really see it anywhere
else where in the case of a draw
Armageddon will decide everything well
absolutely this is a very unique event
like this that they really want to have
a winner right we cannot eliminate draw
itself from the game so they want to
make it break down so it's just we have
a winner yeah and I just love the unique
uh kind of time formats here we started
with the blitz yesterday now we have
classical the Armageddon will be quick
we'll be fast furious as well and yeah
the players that will be having to do
these calculations of points uh how
things break down uh throughout their
games and uh I think that's something
that we'll discuss as we do begin yeah
and uh there we can see the players they
are getting ready and when it comes to
the points breakdown they can see Aryan
tari there
he will be facing off with the black
pieces against Shakura mamajarov and
when it comes to this unique format you
know the players
do have to prepare for a classical game
and then they might have to also have a
plan B in case the game goes to
Armageddon will there be a employing
different strategies do you think I
think definitely the players have
different strategies sometimes probably
it's not game one but later stages of
the tournament it can easily happen that
somebody says well okay I try out
something if I get nothing I'm not going
to push it too hard because I'm very
happy to go to the Armageddon so I think
people will be changing their strategies
from round round you think so and what
do you think David yeah especially those
players with the white pieces in the
Armageddon they will need to win to get
uh to get maximum points and I think
that they have to come armed with maybe
more aggressive openings for the
Armageddon and yeah it's uh it's gonna
be interesting to see how players Target
specific opponents of course in such a
stacked field everyone is extremely
strong but you do get the impression
that against certain players they'll
take it a bit easier against others
they'll go hard and they'll go strong to
try and uh win and here we see farrugia
adjusting his pieces a bit of a custom a
bit of a habit for all the top players
and he starts with the white pieces a
very important game for these two
teenagers certainly and interestingly
enough farrugia sorry came
it wasn't for Richard it was Abdul sator
of who I was thinking about he had the
first pick of the seedings and he did
not choose to start with a double white
and it was for Rouge he had the second
Pig who chose to begin with a double
White
yeah he wants the momentum for Rouge he
wants to start on a high and uh also
Nakamura starts the event with two
blacks in a row and that is fascinating
to me he chose that uh it's clear to me
that he wants to get all the nastiness
out the way as soon as possible uh he
wants to get to the suffering out the
way with black and focus on scoring
heavily later with the white pieces well
this is very interesting in chess that
how the players are handling this kind
of psychological pressure whether you
play with two white so you have to
really show that you take the initiative
and you should be perform and win at
least one game out of the two right
while playing with the black having two
blacks it's like you're trying to
survive and if even if you make two
draws you're kind of happy with yourself
that okay out of two draws I mean the
blacks I made two draws so now I have an
extra white it's kind of the tournament
starts right and so it is very
interesting psychological part but it's
also not easy to play with the white
pieces because when you're white you
definitely have to show that you're
prepared and you have to take the the
lead you have to take the initiative in
the game you have to show that you you
play for a win you you have this energy
so it's uh and of course round one is
always something special because you're
kind of in a warm-up mode and uh there
are different it's like the first round
and the last round I believe it is very
special in the tournament it's certainly
special and uh we can see on the screen
that it was Magnus Carlson he was first
to arrive in his encounter against
Fabiana Carona often we see Magnus
strolling in quite late
yeah normally Magnus uh I think either
by choice or by Design he prefers to
arrive late to avoid the crowds to avoid
uh kind of the autographs the photos
remember this is his home tournament
Magnus Carlson so there'll be throwns of
fans outside her waiting for him every
day but uh it shows he means business
he's looking smart he's looking fresher
uh maybe even yesterday and if he did
get a good night of sleep that could be
decisive for him interesting uh game
ahead this is maybe the Marky match of
the round also a new hairstyle
the man
and there's handshake and they are of
any predictions for the first move oh
well hang on a second Fabian I got there
before of all of us he's opened with a
Kings Born and do you think Magnus all
just the play Sicilian or do you think
he will actually copy I think it goes E5
oh E6
it's your stuff already got to go to
sleep
now Magnus only doubles in the French
defense when he's feeling uh in a mood
for a fight of course there's a huge
risk entailed and this is extra brave
because I've played through fabi's games
I was looking for inspiration from the
white side against the French defense
and Fabiano has almost 100 record
against the French it's just crazy he
seems to win every game so the fact that
Magnus is kind of provoking him like
this
wow uh it takes courage Judah what's
your thoughts on this uh early
development not his normal repertoire
Magnus Castle well I believe that the
simply Magnus is always famous to look
for challenges and he likes to challenge
himself a lot and the problem with this
part that Fabiano has a great score in
the French it makes him even more hungry
to break this this kind of thread for
Fabi and of course when you really play
with someone for years and decades for
so many times you try to to to make a
surprise you try to make something
different
so this is I think this is one of the
biggest challenges and difficulty for
the top players how to keep your
motivation to play against another
player not to repeat the same openings
somehow to create a new idea a new kind
of type of game or provoke your opponent
Nicole a few years ago when Fabiano
started with his wonderful servant out
of seven streak in America St Louis I
remember him beating Magnus in a French
wasn't it
um they had two games there I think
Fabiano beat Magnus was in an
accelerated Dragon okay when Fabiano had
the white pieces uh at least that was
the opening I'm not sure the result in
that game he got one and a half out of
two against Magnus in that tournament
but uh either way I think they have had
the French against each other Ivanka I
think you're right Magnus has uh kind of
poked the bear with the French defense
on occasion against Fabiano and this is
the position we do have it's the
classical variation of the French white
with a lot of space but black is going
to try and chip away at White's Pawn
Center and this won't have come as too
much of a surprise uh like you said
Judith Magnus normally plays E5 he plays
the Sicilian and these guys have had
countless battles in those openings but
Magnus has been playing the French
consistently in rapping and Blitz chess
uh throughout the last few months and
years so uh Fabi he's uh known to do his
homework extremely well he will have had
this position on the board and now he
has a variety of plans setups to choose
from well I love this position to be
honest from the right side when I was
practically playing only once I think
the French in classical
a cram Nick I think because I just had
such a bad score against him I said okay
I just do something different and he
played the E4 and at the time he was not
such a big player and uh but definitely
I'm uh I prefer to play it from the
white side I always felt very
comfortable with that and but it's a
very challenging position because white
is going to be playing Queen D2 probably
and starting to go long Castle
optionally not all the time but I was a
player who was always looking at that
direction so you can push your pawns on
the king side with G4 and F5
but it can also go different a little
bit if the c5d4 pawns are going to be
exchanged then it is a can be a little
different
and black is going to be playing B5 so
black is pushing his pawns on the queen
side while white is pushing the pawns
with G4 not G3 or F5 Knight F4 so in
this game it can easily happen that
let's say in the first 30 moves there is
not going to be even an exchange of any
piece or any pawns yeah just a really
tense position and 92 isn't the main
move you mentioned Judith White normally
just kind of by default plays the move
Queen D2 here I guess he's ready to just
cement the pawn Center if he gets the
pawn to C3 he's built this beautiful
Pawn chain so it's now the moment for
Magnus to do something I guess either
you trade in the center or comes to mind
that you can maybe attack this pawn and
sometimes you can get away with grabbing
this Pawn if you're feeling really Brave
it does feel like white is slightly
slowed down their development with
Knight to E2 this retreating move at the
same sorry I was just gonna say it does
feel like the time is now for black to
do something because I mean I love these
positions from the white side if white
is able to reinforce the pawn Center as
you mentioned and then you have the
freestyle the free hand sorry to attack
on the king side it's interesting in
this structure is that it's always a
question that who is going to give up
the tension in the center is white going
to be taking on C5 and then Place some
piece probably the Knight on D4 or is it
going to be black to capture it on D4
but as you said David C3 is the next
move so if black is not reacting by
playing C takes D4 which is not very
logical in some way because the Knight
E2 really has a great sense right if
black captures on the fortnite D4
immediately at the same time black can
bring his Knights through C5 to E4
and let's see Queen B6 the most typical
move of the French right yes it's very
thematic it puts pressure on the white
B2 Pawn which is currently undefended
but also uh some tactical ideas
potentially uh on the center maybe along
this diagonal and it is a bit awkward
for white to defend the spawn you'd
never really want to step it forward you
will create dark squared weaknesses uh
in the white position while Quincy won
immediately from Fabiano this looks
slightly awkward but again if he gets
one more move to play C3 at the same
time if you think about it there is not
much of a choice for white probably
Queen C1 was the only move because B3 is
is not a move right you don't want to
make weaknesses Rook B1 is not really a
move either because possibly Queen A5
check so it seems like a very different
Theory developing nowadays when I was
playing still back almost a decade ago
Quincy one kind of things we didn't do
in these positions but with the engines
of course life is developing differently
yeah we can be sure that Fabiano has
checked this with an engine and I have a
feeling that Magnus will be surprised by
this plan it feels like Magnus tried to
do the surprising but he's the one who's
now reacting to a new position uh you
can kind of see body language Magnus is
going to be deep I don't think he Minds
no right I think he he likes new things
new ideas to to think about it to think
what kind of plan is really matching
here what are the drawbacks of having
the queen on C1 instead of having it on
D1 C2 other is there a momentum now that
he has to take on D4 and bring out the
bishop to F5 for example to C5
I think he'll he'll like it this fresh
position as long as he doesn't get hit
by more opening Theory a bit later a bit
deeper on but uh let's uh allow Magnus a
few minutes to mull over this position
uh maybe let's zoom out and see how the
openings have progressed on the other
boards uh we do have four other games in
action five games every day we're really
spoiled for choice in terms of where to
go and uh still early stages of course
in all of the games do any positions
catch you right Ivanka
yeah I was uh let's uh
um just looking at the they all seem
quite normal at the minute but I guess
the one that kind of catches my eye the
most just because I want to see how
these players are getting on is the game
between alireza farouza and uh good cash
and okay it looks like a normal boring
type of game but I'm interested in how
both sides are kind of like developing
their forces I mean what kind of mindset
what kind of approach have they gone for
and because one thing I've noticed about
ferrugio is that his technique
is pretty exceptional but it's sometimes
a little bit shaky
yeah let's definitely uh let's start
with that game let's go around the horn
and maybe do an uh an update on how all
of the openings have progressed uh
Ivanka mentioning that uh yeah Allah is
occasionally a bit inconsistent but uh
he's very dangerous with the white
pieces I've suffered on the black side
of the Italian game against him in the
grand Swiss he killed my hopes in the
final rounds of uh getting to the
candidates in this opening in this exact
position pretty much so he knows his
stuff and I think there against me he
played the move uh H2 to H3 and Allah is
he's an expert on all the little details
the little nuances you can try and do
without this move you can just Retreat
the White Knight bring it round sit it
nice and pretty on the G3 square at the
right moment later white will be pushing
for D4 and uh yeah Judith this one's
gonna be a lot of maneuvering over the
next few minutes
yeah well it's Italian
and uh interesting that yesterday we saw
some games having being the pawn on A4
right so on the queen side it's always a
question after A5 white does not have an
opportunity to play B4 and game space
but it's a question whether white plays
a for later or wants to keep the pawn
still there and yeah I agree that of
course the knight from D2 will be
transferred for to F1 most likely I was
never playing the Italian you know with
the white pieces somehow I liked more
the Rye Lopez until Berlin started to
stop me from enjoying it
one E4 killer the villain yeah so Knight
F1 is on the board
and what was it that didn't attract you
to the Italian game because I guess it's
kind of a very similar opening that
almost related the Italian and the
Spanish uh both openings do lead to
maybe more maneuvering positions with
this white Bishop out I think the Ryan
Lopez I like that it was more
straightforward I was playing lines
where after C3 you played D4 and not D3
so white has the space advantage and I
was kind of happy and prepared for the
different lines black was playing
and here I'm I'm kind of worried many
times about black playing D5 and black
is taking the initiative from the other
side at the same time I know that it's
not so simple for black to play D5
because the Rook is only one night and
F3 putting pressure on on the E5 phone
and even if black gets to play D5 things
are not so simple for black if black
white reaches the Knight G3 to Knight E4
it can be very unpleasant so black has
to be very careful when he can play D5
and now we see A4 what we just discussed
whether right to have A4 on the board is
good or not so black has his uh way of
thinking and planning
yeah and I've always found this plan is
black uh very controversial just pushing
the pawn forward is very ambitious of
course but this Pawn can become weak in
certain variations I remember analyzing
if not this exact position then
something uh very similar where white
goes hunting already for this Pawn on A4
and it gets very very sharp you try and
provoke the black pawn forward if it
steps even further forward it might end
up a weakness on the Square white will
bypass with B4 and uh the lines get very
complicated also watch out for the black
Rook lifting to A5 some crazy variations
have been discovered in recent times of
The Rook sitting on A5 the bishop
dropping back and The Rook supporting
that D5 push you mentioned later on
Judith so what about Bishop B5 right now
I think that's the big question I was
going to ask the same thing because this
is very much the modern approach right
just to push your pieces forward push
your pawns forward and just take the
space because I've been reading some
some books about the older Masters and
there they were very hesitant about
pushing pawns they said you know if you
push pawns you leave behind weak squares
and you've got to guard those squares
and it seems like modern JHS is not
really about that
yes because time is a very important
factor in chess and I'm not thinking
about the clock right now but I'm
talking about the tempos right so after
Bishop B5 maybe for example Bishop G4
makes a lot of sense so in case Bishop
A4 then Bishop F3 would be possible to
take and the queen cannot take back only
the pawn from G2 has to capture back and
the pawn structure is not something that
white can be very happy with
but I'm not sure it gives anything great
for black or enough compensation playing
Knight H5 going Knight F4 Queen H4 it
kind of looks like a good Archangel for
black
yeah it looks like a variation of the
Spanish the Ivanka you're right and
there's so many little details just to
show one variation that I've analyzed
but uh is completely different here uh
move water is so important if we
backtrack to this position where
ferrugia has uh just played the move
Knight to F1 If instead he had played H3
then A4 is indeed one of the main lines
and you can justify this tactically by
playing the move Bishop D7 it looks a
bit crazy giving up the pawn but now you
can cash in Rook takes A4 and here
there's moose like Knight to B4
discovered attack against the queen
black is a load of material down but
next move you're going to take this Pawn
on D3 and the position gets crazy so now
all of these uh little details are
different this time because white has
dropped the Knight back to F1 and after
A4 Bishop B5 this is no longer possible
this whole variation uh because Knight
to B4 it can simply be map my queen to
D1 and the difference is this Pawn is
protected and that's why the Italian
game for me has been so confusing my
whole life just one tiny move order
change and everything is completely
different
that was a very flashy line there you
showed loved it
it was unexpected unexpected and that's
why I keep losing on the black side of
the Italian game because I always try to
make these little tactics work and then
my opponent plays one little move and
suddenly you've got to find a totally
different plan and farusha now in the
tank I think he's mulling over the
concepts of going after this black porn
the Intruder on A4 but uh we'll let him
think about whether to go for it
immediately or whether to continue
maneuvering simply the problem might be
that Knight to G3 in this position will
be met by black hunting down White's
light squared Bishop so complicated
position at an early stage
sadly and uh shall we take a zoom out
and have another walk around the park
yeah and uh let's check in next on the
All-American clash between hikara and
Nakamura and Wesley so this is early
days uh let's get this position out the
way quickly I came to this one Judith
because you mentioned the Berlin and it
is the Berlin defense the most solid
opening in chess and it's early stages
but uh looking very balanced so far and
uh we see Wesley on the camera deep in
thought Hikaru away from the board this
is the position they've gotten maybe
let's do a recap from move one uh just
to show what's happened white played one
one E4 it was the Spanish opening and a
true detention Knight F6 well this is
what turned me away from playing the
Spanish as well the Royal Lopez and not
the Antebellum allowing a capture here
and it's the symmetrical variation so
lots of Trades already at this early
stage I guess the main interest is white
dropping Back The Rook to an unnatural
Square on E2 this one is very
provocative I guess the plus side is
that sometimes you can line up your
queen behind your Rook to control the
open file but at the same time The Rook
does Block in the white bishop and just
to catch up with the current position
white has just played Pawn to D5 so
Wesley showing ambition gaining space
well uh yeah I've seen this position for
a long time
and trying to squeeze out some Advantage
for white side basically white uh aim is
to get a more pleasant position because
you're not really going to get a clear
Advantage right and after D5 the idea is
that it's important that it stops black
from playing D5 and after that the
bishop would be coming out to F5 G4
Knight can come back to D6 so it would
be kind of very comfortable for black so
white is gaining space of the D5 at the
same time the F6 Bishop can be much more
powerful than without white playing the
E5 so white wants to play later C3 or in
some occasion C4 develop the bishop the
big question and the the challenge for
black what he's going to be doing with
his knight from E8 right so most likely
is going with G6 Knight G7 at some point
the question is now black is going to be
developing the bishop C8 Bishop with D6
Bishop D7 or Bishop F5 or the other way
somehow rookie to his kind of also
provoking that black is going B6 and
Bishop A6
or Bishop B7
so the next four or five moves will
decide whether white can really play for
something or there is not much I have
the feeling that it's a it's a typical
round one game you don't want to go and
put all in right you go for solid I mean
they also have a pass they have they
respect each other they would want to
win but not by any cost
true yeah he feels like the type of
position for weight where you can always
pull the reverse break uh just kind of
yeah if you need to then you can bail
out with the draw a bit later on if you
lose a bit of control but D6 from
Nakamura another plan might be to try
and fight against this kind of strong
point the spearhead of White's position
on D5 maybe C6 Knight to C7 and black is
very very solid I mean while white might
be trying to get the Knight to E4 to at
least grab the bishop pair for his
troubles yeah early stages but looking
balance certainly looking balanced um
I'm sure lots of people will be asking
at home why did white put the Rook on E2
I mean what superpower does it have
there uh
that's a good question well first of all
what David said that Queen Eve want to
have the battery there it many times
it's more powerful right the other
reason is that white might be
considering that it's not really
important to have the diagonal and the
openness of the F1 Bishop because it's
not useful so much it can also be at
some point let's say if white is going
C4 then Bishop F4 can be played and on
the second rank the B2 Pawn is the
defended and it can also be that white
is just going to be developing with the
bishop Knight and the Queen and already
white is ready to double The Rook from
A1 to E1
sophisticated stuff it's very
complicated yeah and I first saw this
idea in the world championship match in
2016 between Magnus Carlson and Sergey
kariakin and there The Rook dropped to
E2 black played a move like B6 and then
the Rook just dropped back to E1 to
evade Bishop A6 and uh White is just
arguing that black is actually weakening
himself uh themselves and uh it was
really argue on that one yeah exactly I
agree you know there are some situations
and moves but I believe that if it's
Magnus who plays it it's kariakin or
some very top players playing it you say
Wow Let's see and discover what is the
deepness of this if it would be let's
say 300 rating or 500 rating point less
you would just say come on you lost the
tempo
you said it not me
I I mean it's true though yeah and often
these top players I mean they they lose
the plot a bit because they're looking
at the computer and they'll probably see
that rookie one it might be the top move
but rookie two is maybe the third best
move and it doesn't change the
evaluation much so why not experiment
why not try to kind of weird out the
opponent by playing these strange moves
and get them thinking at an early stage
um so the problem is it's very much
Theory and all the top players are
analyzing this with engines so they try
to look for something really really
small little different idea if you do
the same things maybe I will have a
little idea that it can confuse the
opponent so
yeah early days I think we'll backtrack
to this one a bit later on to see how
white deals with the weird uh the
strange placement of his Rook on E2 but
either way it looks like Nakamura has a
few questions to solve before he can
fully claim equality so uh let's go back
to the bird's eye view and uh I think
we've seen three of the of the five
games so far at this early stage let's
check check in on one of those that we
haven't maybe Abdul sator of the winner
of yesterday's Blitz event against Anish
Gary and uh this one
of course a big game and okay a lot of
moves at this early stage it's uh
big game for Abdul satorov if he can
continue his form I think he'll be full
of confidence and he'll be a hard man to
stop at these early stages and uh yeah
soon I want to ask predictions for all
of the games from the both of you but
first let's delve into this one with
anishagiri away from the board Abdus
sitting there mulling over his position
let's just do a quick recap as we did
with the other games on the opening so
this is the current position let's see
how we got there it was a queen's Pawn
opening and it was a variation of the
Queen's Gambit declined which would be
seven
and a variation with dtec C4 not the
normal move normally black just simply
castles kingside instead black is happy
to trade off a set of Pawns giving white
an isolated Queen's Pawn but it has come
at the cost of time and the last move
from Knight C6
what are our thoughts at this early
stage isolated Queen spawn can lead to
some quite Dynamic play
I got the the isolated phone from the
car company of attack that's what I
played with white but in those systems
most of the time I have my Bishop still
on C1 and of course isolated Pawn it's a
completely different structure and it
has a completely different Dynamic white
has to be energetic and straightforward
because if some of the pieces are going
to be exchanged let's say then a white
can get very easily dangerous position
karpov like to play very much from the
black side I had several games with him
also and what is interesting idea here
with black in the next moves after H6
Bishop H4 what is very typical to go
Knight H5 and try to exchange simplify
exchange the black Square bishop and it
is very tricky for white what kind of
exchange of pieces can be on favor of
white because usually it's better not to
exchange pieces here yeah I think that's
a very thematic plan and a very logical
one often black also just fiancato is
this bishop white needs a breakthrough
or white needs at least some type of uh
attack at an early stage to justify
having this weak born in the center of
course you can always kind of step
forward later on if you really want to
simplify and make a draw but I doubt
Abdus is playing this opening with that
in mind and Judy you mentioned that this
comes from the caricon juvanka's
favorite opening it can also come from
the nimso Indian defense it can come
from C three Sicilians and French
defenses a whole bunch of openings so
this is a core part of players
understanding how to work the iqp the
isolated Queen spawn certainly and I
think it's a wise choice for Manish
because there is a degree of pressure on
the white side that you know that they
have to do something otherwise as you've
both been alluding to Black is simply
going to play for those simplifications
so you know white has to just accelerate
the pain I've actually had lots of games
against you and David yeah and this and
I was suffering in a few of them when I
was young that was the only thing I knew
just isolated Queen's Pawn at any cost
with white with the French Sicilian
karakan I would just get the isolated
Queen spawn and hope to Checkmate but if
I didn't check mate often my opponents
without play me in the end game that's
the problem
but yeah I mean I I just because an
order back of course is a universal
player a fantastic player but I feel
like his skill set is more to the
technical side you give him a small
advantage and he's Relentless with it
and here I think he it's somewhat
uncomfortable for people who are not
naturally so aggressive or so kind of
like
freestyling with their play to kind of
just push their pieces forward and just
hope for the best um my plans that I've
seen as you guys mentioned like just
Castle centralized the Rooks and uh
go for that King side attack but it's
difficult to orchestrate here and
somehow you feel that white should be
perhaps centralizing the Rooks and
Blasting opening in Center yeah maybe we
jump into the analysis board just to
show some plans and uh Ivanka you
mentioned that if white gets time for
example after castling castling uh if
white gets all the Time in the World to
just set up say rookie one black kind of
fianchettos let's say I'll just make
some random moves on the board and uh
something like this if black plays too
slowly then white has a very dangerous
attack white can kind of line up on this
diagonal there'll be some check mating
ideas here against the black king I see
you get enthusiastic about it this is
like my Ultimate Dream as a child
getting a position like this white can
break through in the center and we can
say and point out that it's very
important in this kind of position
already that black played H6 which
actually gives a great weakness for
black because after Bishop B1 when black
has to play G6 also then all kind of
Rook A6 Jack sacrifices can arrive there
so the point should would be much better
standing on H7 yeah just to show your
ideas
we are in the mood we're in the mood to
check look at the bar this is definitely
going to happen
but uh yes the problem for white here
this is all beautiful of course and this
will lead to Checkmate the problem here
as uh as Judah said black is not obliged
to play slowly and ideas such as Knight
H5 as you mentioned getting these
Bishops off the board tends to be the
antidote this was only discovered
I guess by players who kind of
understood the dangers of keeping the
pieces on the board and now black is
totally fine you've got pressure along
this diagonal white has no more attack
than I can often jump in or jump back
and sit in this Outpost in front of the
isolated Queen's pawn and
if this type of thing happens often it
can backfire and white so obvious let's
go back to the game has just castled and
we will await developments here it's all
definitely a matter of time and it's a
bit of a race who can attack first or
who can simplify first if you are an
ishigiri and for sure he's worked out
the details he knows his stuff Anish and
uh in the opening he's the one that I
defer to in these types of positions as
well and he immediately castles back as
black
very solid play solid stuff
yeah and also not only night H5 but also
Knight D5 is something which is very
common right it's the only thing let's
say after rookie one if Knight D5 is
blood
it is a very common way of a transition
in a isolated bomb positions after
Knight D5 Bishop D5 ed5 and then we have
a full symmetrical position
uh which which is a kind of position
it's not for everybody and it's kind of
lifeless position very very positional
so Knight D5 Knight H5 with black or
really playing B6 as you showed and
Bishop B7 that's uh that's the most
common plans and the the only thing is
that why for example after rookie one E6
D5 might be strong I think or it has to
be considered right yeah let's maybe
jump in and show that uh some of the
dangers that await black if you are
careless after rookie one which we are
expecting a very logical move B6 maybe
D5 and uh here there are some tactics
you have to calculate all sorts of
things maybe Knight A5 for black hitting
this bishop but uh yeah if you do take
it so possible if you do take in the
center then this could backfire lots of
options for white I'm not sure which one
to go for but uh for example just taking
back and this one gets sharp some stuff
hanging this bishop hanging yeah but it
seems like black is completely fine
right takes on H4 takes on C6 Rook B8
and uh got away with it white is not
fast enough yeah yeah
so these are the lights that the players
will be calculating uh this is the
current position Abdus tour of I should
mention has spent a lot of time 25
minutes up to this point we're only at
move 10 and there's still a very kind of
well-known type of position uh it feels
like the opening's been a successful
Anish giri at least in psychological
terms at this early stage
a lot of life here yeah definitely after
a move uh what is it it's uh it's moved
then or so so you can say that the the
opening battle was won by Anish yep at
least in Surprise uh surprise value and
uh just for completeness I think there's
one other game uh let's check in on the
opening there before we decide where to
focus and uh let's go back to the bird's
eye view uh the game we haven't
mentioned so far is Shakira mamajarov as
white against ariantari and this is uh
yeah a big Clash Ariane the lowest rated
seed in the tournament by quite a
distance actually so a lot of players
will be targeting him he starts with
black yesterday he had a tough time in
the blitz tournament but did defeat
Magnus Carson with the black thesis so a
bit of uh confidence there for him and
maybe are for some fire yesterday he
starts with white and this is the
current position early thoughts Judith
well uh what I realized is that uh well
the black Square Bishop was exchanged
which I don't know who does it favors
it uh it looks kind of a little bit also
kind of a pun of attack from the other
side the reverse colors
this kind of strange for me I would
think that with white
probably B3 might be a plan to to break
up the C4 bone or also Knight E5 I would
consider as an option uh to go for
it looks a pretty balanced game for me
so far and Ivanka uh Judith mentioned
the point that it looks basically like a
caracon with reverse colors I know and
uh it was quite nice because I was able
to apply those patterns from there and I
know that B3 is definitely an idea and
something that I wrote in my Caro book
is like when you see that pawn structure
it's a good idea to jump in with a
knight into the center and uh just to
disrupt the harmony of Black's position
and also at the same time Target the D5
Pawn which doesn't have any support
yeah often this is a big weakness and uh
just again for completeness sake let's
go back from the start just to play
through the first 10 moves still early
days here this game started as an
English opening and to go through
quickly we did see this transposed later
to a queen's porn opening the Queen's
gamber declined and here it's the taresh
variation and here we did see white not
choosing to capture this Pawn maybe the
critical uh Concepts here to try and
take up Black's Gambit where where I
guess Black's plan was to step forward
with D4 instead right just lock down the
center and this is how we got
current position and yeah those two
plants on top but I also believe that
sometimes strong players and experienced
players like mamajarov as well they
might simply choose an opening and
decide to go to this direction where the
opponent can be not so experienced and
maybe he believes that okay I'm just
going to be out playing my opponent it's
not that why it has a great advantage or
anything like that basically it's
important whether you're familiar with
the structures with the plans with the
ideas
and and this is a very unusual position
to me to be honest
look at this I mean B3 somehow once
wants to be played in this position I
don't like it if black is able to play
A6 and B5 let's say because somehow then
black is taking over the initiative on
the queen side and there is not much on
the king side that the white can be
proud of
yeah this is true and it is ariane's
move as black so maybe this is what
he'll go for just supporting his uh
Advanced Pawn here uh as you're both uh
kind of hinting at there if Black's Pawn
ever gets exchanged if white does get
time now to play B3 and we see an
exchanger on the Square black is left
with a long-term isolated Pawn on D5
long term weakness and it could be
one-sided traffic later in the end game
which color I would pick to be honest
whether I would rather play it with the
black side or the white side which one
would you pick toss a coin I'm happy
with either side here all right I think
maybe I would slightly prefer black just
because uh well if I can keep this Pawn
on C4 just because it feels like white
is struggling for a concrete plan but
it's also very interesting I think
I think this uh
idea that many
just because we
we see someone playing from the white
side we tend to think that the white is
kind of a little bit better maybe it's
an equilish position
much easier say that white is maybe
slightly better where I can say I mean
in this position also I can say that if
we just paint the reverse the older
pieces then I'm not sure whether if the
eye would be black which is white color
whether well maybe I would say well I'm
really trying to fight for Equalization
right and it goes the same to the other
game where we are going to go back with
Nakamura the Berlin it's also like just
because you're playing with the white
pieces it doesn't mean that you're
having the offer
yeah I guess that's why there's this
Modern Trend of everyone playing
openings just with reverse colors one
extra Tempo because yeah they're
colorblind at this point right they're
just happy to play any position as long
as there's a dynamic potential but yeah
let's check back in on this one later
let's zoom out and go to the bird's eye
view definitely and
as we
take a look at the bird's eye view I
think
I think break of the day the tension is
starting to build and it's all looking
like it's exciting stuff and of course
don't miss your chance because something
special is coming up don't miss your
chance to win Diamond membership this
Friday the chess.com Discord server is
hosting an arena with four Diamond
memberships up for grabs to stake your
claim join the Discord at go.chess.com
forward slash Discord then connect your
chess.com account and you're done you
now can complete compete in the weekly
arena for our Discord community and win
free Diamond membership use x-clamp
Discord in chat now
and
that's a time for a quick break as uh
we're going to join the action see you
on the other side
[Music]
foreign
oh yeah do you want to be black
okay
we have a no boys loud chess club
because it feels like in chess sometimes
there's too many boys who are just
you know critical or judgmental it's a
pretty intimidating space where it can
be when you go to a chess club and
there's no other girls there so we want
this to be a place where girls feel
comfortable playing chess it doesn't
matter if you're good or a beginner
that's what the chess cave is for
foreign
[Music]
hello and we are back after that short
breather and time to reignite that chess
fire and there we can see Fabiana
carrona playing with the white pieces
against none other than Magnus Carlson
you have to remember back in 2018 these
two faced off against each other for
that world championship crown and take a
look at some of Fabiano Coronas and very
impressive achievements as a reigning
two-time U.S champion in 2018 he was the
world championship runner-up when he
lost it Magnus Carlson and he's got the
highest tournament performance rating in
classical chess history look at that 30
98 3098 I don't even know how to say
that and then the third highest video
rating in chess history of 28.44 very
very impressive player he's known for
his calculating skills and he's got the
white pieces against none other than
Magnus Carlsen in the first round round
of no HS and well and I can just look at
that position that I can see on the
board I mean it's looking wild already
oh a lot very wild so far no peace was
exchanged as we expected Bishop G2 was
just played why it wants to Castle I
guess in the next move
that's a big question whether anything
any tension can uh can be broken there
in the center because of course the
white always has to look after some kind
of uh breaking out for black taking on
D4 taking on E5 or even sacrificing
something in the center specifically on
E5 but for the moment it seems that
white is really defending every single
piece so Queen on C1 after all it would
be just fine on D2 but white did not
have time in previous situations to play
Queen D2 and having C3 at the same time
so that's why we see the queen on C1
because only later C4 C3 was played so
I'm expecting actually later on after
castle of short uh short Castle to have
Queen D2 placing it to a better place
but it can be actually a very nice
position for white if black cannot break
something up in the center
yeah I completely agree it feels like
the stakes are far higher for Magnus
here than they are for Fabiano and uh
yeah after Bishop G2 I'm just loving
White's Pawn chain you look at the
center here it's like a Christmas tree
maneuver as Judith mentions you can
Castle you can bring your queen forward
start bringing this Rook into the game
slide it across you could start pushing
pawns against the black king you have a
variety of plans to choose from for
black for Magnus Carlson it's much
harder for example where is this knight
ever going to go if it can't sacrifice
itself to break open the pawn Center do
you really have to step back in some uh
in some cases how to develop the bishop
behind it these are two big problem
pieces it feels like you're lacking
plans do you have to move the queen out
the way to start pushing pawns forward
it takes so long and I'm not sure black
has that luxury so right now could be a
critical moment for Magnus Castle yeah
and I was Consulting the opening
database while David was talking and I
and there is an alternative plan which
has been played twice and there's only
been two games in the database so far
and that's actually black as times
capture the pawn in the middle they
couldn't handle the tension okay which
porn you've anchor on yes before yeah D4
sorry
and uh maybe we can dive in and see how
those previous uh games went the
predecessors of in this position what
happened after C takes D4 C takes D4
um both games are actually funny enough
I actually ended up with black capturing
another Pawn in the center one takes
porn
and uh in fact black actually has a good
score 67 but you know the mod the uh
pool of games is quite low
and uh just because it's such a critical
moment still a couple of Pawn trades
haven't really changed too much uh can I
ask for another move or two to see what
happened Queen check queen queen four
sorry hang on hang on no Queen B5 sorry
okay Queen B5 interesting Judah you
mentioned this plan of white castling
now of the black queen keeps this Knight
under uh watchful gaze so castling not
possible and I guess the idea if the
Knight hits the queen is to jump in it
is wow creative stuff and this is the
type of thing that might be needed just
to hold the balance for black if you
don't find something creative you'll
just get squashed slowly at the same
time I was considering after Queen B5
which is a very interesting move to play
Knight F4 so stopping the queen to go to
D3 I cannot castle in the next move
that's something that I would be unhappy
with and that can be a problem but I'm
attacking on E6
yeah and I see the evaluation part drop
here what could the idea be for black
maybe some kind of Knight B4 and uh F4 I
do three ideas oh nice so uh just to
show your idea if the pawn steps up rook
takes Knight and yep you want to jump in
with a nasty check a family Fork of
Royal Fork on D3
I guess that wouldn't uh be allowed by
whites this is such a crazy position
though after Knight to B4 it feels like
maybe white can drop back and hit but
undeveloping pieces is counter-intuitive
doesn't feel right even the computer
can't make up its mind evaluation bar
there but you know what maybe after
Knight F4 uh maybe G5 can beat the move
and sacrificing the E6 and Knight B4 I
don't know but some a lot of tactical
ideas coming up here a G5 is my instinct
and also I remember Fabi just recently
having a game where I think it was in
the chess kids where his opponent like
lashed out with G5 and suddenly oops
Fabi was in big trouble yeah you're
right that was also in the French
defense against Alexander shimanov and
uh that was equally dramatic Fabi did
later turn around that game as white but
yeah this would be easy to miss you
could you could kind of play a move like
Knight F4 think you're winning think you
or not maybe not winning but you think
you have a big Advantage but suddenly
you get hit by a move like G5 and
suddenly your position might fall apart
so the stakes incredibly high and if we
go back to the game position it's here
Magnus needs something if he doesn't
find this idea with maybe trading
everything and going Queen B5 then I do
fear for his chances but I think maybe
between B5 can be played immediately or
after she takes D4 Queen B5 so it's a
very interesting and smart idea to stop
white from castling right because if
white has the time forecastling windy
too everything is protected then white
will have a huge Advantage I think very
pleasant position for white to play yeah
and maybe that's why the placement of
the queen is so important if the queen
was on D2 white would have everything
under control you're kind of guaranteed
to Castle on the next couple of moves
but uh Magnus he's spent almost 20
minutes up to this point he needs to
kind of invest more time now and he gets
away from the board
at the same time Fabiana was spending 30
minutes up to this point already
so both players it feels like they're
freestyling and I was confused there
Magnus got up from the board but it was
his move still he was just uh taking off
his jacket just getting comfortable and
I think he realizes this is a critical
moment the top players do that they're
always really aware of when the games
could be decided long term and this
feels like a key moment
certainly a key moment and I I just kind
of was inspired to ask you both a
question because I know when it comes to
like business and the approaches that
you should have to improving the
marketing side they always encourage you
that you know you zoom in and then you
zoom out
is this particular approach like
relevant for chess like in terms of like
first of all you have your calculations
and then of course you should step back
and have a look at the bigger picture
well I would say uh zooming out zooming
in especially for example after a time
travel
when you played everything very fast you
could not follow exactly what was going
on there are different exchanges Bond
structure change everything
in that moment after move 40 for example
I'm always
convinced that the best thing you can do
is instead of making the next move go
out to the bathroom take a walk or
whatever zoom out get rid of all the the
tension and all the calculations and all
the changes what has happened and then
go back with the fresh eye there for
example I think it's a must because many
times there are many mistakes done
because your your mind is still on the
previous Pawn structure or still what it
was and you're trying to fix it and
there's a completely different picture
already
and I'm getting flashbacks to Ivanka you
mean you mentioned zooming out and only
then making a decision when you're kind
of a bit calmer uh I mean the number of
angry emails or emotional texts that
I've sent without uh kind of taking a
step back
I wish I could take back and regret uh
it's the same in chess it's like you
don't want to make an emotional move
right you want that moment back and
actually since I became a commentator
that now I talk to myself more during a
game I remember we had a conversation in
the car Judy you were saying you think
purely in moves so mostly in moves
nowadays I add words to kind of
explanations to myself and at least the
thought process is a bit cleaner but
yeah of course calculation just as
important and uh yeah I definitely feel
it helps to kind of combine just pure
moves pure variations with a little bit
of perspective a little bit of calmness
as well C takes D4 you'll move on the
board you anchor yeah and uh if it
happens it does look like black does
have their fair share of chances but as
you guys mentioned in the the shoe is on
black foot he has to play in a very
accurate way
and we like the start and Fabiano taking
a small pause again good strategy here
white most likely it's going to take
back with the pawn you want to keep your
Pawn structure intact to that nice
little formation we showed earlier but
you could make us an argument
potentially of uh taking on D4 with the
Knights so the top players they tend to
just do this they tend to double check
on any automatic recaptures just in case
there might be a stronger continuation
yeah because Knight E 2 to D4 it also
has uh quite a logical idea behind it
right if the center is not falling apart
after fe5 or something then it could be
a very sensible move at the same time of
course the first move comes to mind that
you have to keep the chain of the bones
and capture it with the pawn
yep so first instinct you definitely
want to take back with your Pawn here
but uh yeah Knight takes D4 I'm not sure
what exactly what would happen but for
example the type of chaos that could
ensue you could take this Pawn Knight
takes E6 D4 and it just gets totally
messy I mean probably this is fine for
white or good for white even but this is
the type of thing you would have to
calculate just to justify such a kind of
critical decision
but on a practical level I mean would
you go into this and
because you know this you'd need to burn
a lot of time on the clock calculating
every single consequence here because
the white king is stuck in the middle of
the board and bearing in mind that you
won't get that increment until after
move 40.
do you make that investment
for me actually I was surprised that
Fabi was spending even a minute once he
takes D4 because somehow it also depends
what kind of self-confidence you have
and how sure are you about what you're
doing and about the position I think
many of the players would just wouldn't
even think about it and play instantly
see things before yeah and he did
eventually yeah but I think Fabio's may
be one of a kind in that regard at the
top level he will pause and calculate
everything to the end just to double
check things Magnus for example and some
others at the top level they'll be quite
instinctive they'll play c64 and it's
the move they want to play if there's
any issues they'll worry about that a
bit later and uh you also mentioned
Ivanka the lack of increments in at
least the first 40 moves of this
tournament during the world championship
match ding against nepo the lack of
increment made it far more exciting
right
led to more drama
with no increment it it makes a
different game especially towards the
time control is completed because uh
well I remember those days when I was
playing in Linares and Evancho had let's
say one minute with 20 moves you know
and he was not the only one doing
something like this and it was the same
thing for karpov he was a huge time
travel player well you're also a time
travel player aren't you dude I didn't
know carpool first I've seen some games
if it's where he's in time trouble but I
didn't know it was a bit of a habit oh
yeah so after this this whole official
clock came into fashion in the early
2000 years I think then it was a great
relief for carpool for example or or any
of the the very heavy time travel
players because it was a life changer
yeah I think I would have retired if I
had to play games with zero increment I
would retired years ago but do you guys
like this step back from a spectator
point of view because I personally love
it I mean I love the drama I love the
kind of the sheer relief on players
faces where they make that time control
and you can see them go and I can I like
it when they're shaking
um please tell me I'm not the only one
tell you the truth I think simply a
professional player
they should be understood for them that
they have to take care of of their time
and uh well sorry David they're saying
this I appreciate it but I remember when
I was in my top years I was not a time
travel player at all and when I started
to feel that I'm kind of running of out
of time I didn't have heavy time
troubles but let's say having 10 minutes
for six moves or something and I felt
very very uncomfortable already so I
think generally the also youngsters when
I talk to them I tell them that you just
have to know what you're doing whether
it's good or not but the time is a
priority that you save your time for
really really bad times because once you
have no time you can't concentrate you
can't focus I think the only player I
know who can focus at least as good is
grischuk and and David is also good but
Christian is the the guy who can
sometimes play even better than if he's
not in time I'm like a budget I'm like a
poor man's grishock
but I have noticed one thing with David
is when he does get himself into time
travel they're rarely sharp positions
and so he can make those kind of like
easy moves or not easy moves but safety
moves quite quickly but you keep us
entertained oh yeah it's very
entertaining that's for sure but for the
player it's uh it's it's a very
stressful lot of energy a lot of
emotions I think so it takes a lot of
energy away in a tournament but of
course from commentator point of view
I'm very much enjoying it that they
don't have extra time and when I was a
player for me it was kind of a serious
change because I was very good at how
I'm consuming my time and also I was
playing in a very practical way so I
made my opponent think and make choices
and decisions so they were eating up
their time and then when they were in
time travel I also made some surprising
move and the time was a very serious
issue while later on when it was 30
seconds per move that's a different
story because you don't find the your
opponent having two minutes for 12 moves
let's say because they always gain time
so I had to a little bit change also my
mindset and it's just uh gave a thought
to me where I was thinking when you guys
are playing chess are you emotional I'm
by emotional I obviously I don't mean
like crying or whatever I just mean you
know are you happy are you excited I
mean or do you try to Flatline that as
much as possible
oh that's one thing I've struggled with
until maybe the last few years Ivanka
especially in final rounds of
tournaments I'm always thinking about
the result the prize money you know the
emotion the uh everything that's at
stake and I that really affected my
judgment I think that was a three-year
period in my career where I just never
won a last round because I was just uh
kind of too much in my own head and
that's one thing I noticed the top
players are so good at maybe because
they play so much these days all of them
uh they kind of can take a step back if
they lose fine they'll have another
tournament uh next week and yeah emotion
at the chessboard
I don't think it plays too healthy of a
role so uh yeah being in charge of your
emotions I think is a key uh ingredient
to their success these top players how
about YouTube I can absolutely agree on
that I think this is really the key of
success on top level the top level
players they can simply exclude the
world while they are playing and the
less it affects you the better you play
because you really have to be in the
game be in the flow of the game Focus
only there all the nuances has to be the
most important thing for you during the
game right so if it comes into your mind
of the price found the preparation the
the pressure people putting on you the
expectations all these things it's
killing but what about good emotions
like for instance happiness
yeah
I mean is that is that good you know but
like happiness like you guys were
discussing a situation like your
opponents in time travel and for me I'm
literally I'm looking at the clock and
I'm thinking oh they might lose on time
and then I actually feel a bit
disappointed that they don't
and it happens again and I'm wondering
whether you know I should like allow
these positive emotions of excitement
happiness
well I think you can exclude that one
because it's part of the game whether
you're hyped up you're excited but you
have to calm yourself down because all
in all you have to be focusing exactly
on that moment of the game not before
and not too much for farther ahead you
know and of course in a team competition
for example it's even more difficult to
handle yourself you know that it depends
on you it's the last game and the in the
Olympic gold medal or whatever if you
win but it is really important to stay
calm and and just to look at the
position have a healthy understanding of
the position have a healthy
self-confidence keep the balance and I
think this is why the youngsters can be
sometimes more efficient and playing
better because you don't feel that they
would care they are just Brave they
don't care I lose today I win tomorrow
it doesn't affect them so heavily
because when emotionally it affects you
then it's already a problem so you
really have to work on that very much I
think the psychological aspect that
really focusing on the moves on the game
on the on the depths of the chess ideas
yeah having no fear it's uh also uh yeah
it's a key ingredient and uh talking of
having no fear Magnus now I'm a bit
worried that he's fearful of his own
position he's not played any of those
moves we suggested we were talking about
maybe Queen B5 maybe uh coming note
before giving a check uh he's still
thinking after almost 10 minutes now on
the clock and maybe just while Magnus uh
is in the tank we can zoom out and check
up uh check out some of the other games
there have been big developments in the
All-American Clash uh between Hikaru
Nakamura and Wesley so let's uh zoom out
of this one and jump there I'm fearful
we might see a result in the near future
in this one already and uh Queens are
off the board it's the Berlin after all
that's uh what we're accustomed to and
Judith you mentioned that this opening
was one of the main headaches for any
Spanish player any Roy Lopez player is
this a position that might give Wesley
some headaches in terms of winning
chances
well we can still say I think that the
game is not a draw it's just uh pretty
much equalish position there are still
ways of of trying to to play a game and
play it out I believe F3 is a kind of a
logical move bringing the king to F2
towards the center and also sometimes G4
can be an idea to gain space there is
also an idea I like Knight A5 sometimes
the right to provoke black to make some
weaknesses with B6
something to still play out but I
wouldn't worry much for uh for Nakamura
in this position either he might also
play H5 for example to stop G4
yeah that would be a really classy move
uh it's that's the one thing I'm yet to
master when I see Magnus just throw H5
out randomly it always seems to be an
important inclusion a bit later in the
game but if you're a little fashionable
nowadays you every game you're going to
show up and play H5 or G5 at some point
true that's the motto right if in doubt
if you don't see any good moves just
push your H Pawn but actually I like H5
yeah with the idea to play G5 also bring
the king to G6 I mean black can also
have a nice position
H5 G5 H4 Knight H5 came to F6 Knight F4
I mean if let's say you give me an
opportunity to play six moves with black
I take over and black is better
yeah after all white does have uh most
Central pawns especially this D5 Pawn on
a light Square which could be
overextended white does have a light
squared Bishop which could kind of
become a bad piece a bit later on stuck
behind its own pawns so some uh kind of
hints that black has something to play
for as well but uh yeah I just fear that
all the Rooks will come off or at least
one set of Rooks will come off on the
central e-file on the open file here at
the same time I'm not sure I wouldn't
like to play Rather with black if I
would have the opportunity to play H5 to
start beat G4 then I play A5 possibly
even A4
rookie 8 any time right I mean there is
not no any rush for black to do so
yeah
quite quite a nice idea right to improve
but whereas for why it's not that easy
to progress
yeah I guess white has a lot of kind of
I call them happy moves just to King F2
and I don't know G4 maybe but after my
H5 yeah
that's an unhappy move if you're white
too
but David you know me very well by
progress I mean push pawns get them
closer
exactly on the move and I think white
might play H4 just to stop your ideas of
playing G5 uh maybe that's the best yeah
fix a Pawn on a light square at least
yeah that's a very sensible idea I think
yeah to me it looks just very balanced
and uh the reason I don't kind of
foresee there being a winner in this
game is simply because Wesley's
technique is so good I can't foresee him
getting in any trouble this way to
Nakamura maybe one of the best defenders
ever but especially if this generation
uh it's hard to see black kind of
suffering too much here I do have one
quick question though before we leave
that's quite a technical position
um it is possible for white to actually
jump to the A5 square with the Knight
and attack the B7 pawn and
and the question is like do you does
black just actually defend that pawn
with a with the Rook or actually step
forward with the B6 Pawn because the
reason I'm asking this is because there
could potentially if you kick away the
Knight it could be a trade of a bishop
for a knight and that's like such a
difficult thing to master
yeah let's jump in and uh what do you
think of this one Judith uh if Knight A5
does appear on the board will black be
provoked into playing B6 well I think B6
is a very sensible idea because
I believe it's not exactly so good
because Knight D5 might be possible oops
of course after playing H5 it can be
taken after Rook D5 and Rook H5 but it's
definitely black who is having a great
position having The Rook on H5 he can be
too proud of so black and gold G6 rookie
8 controlling the E file it's definitely
black who wants to be
playing for a win if any anybody
so so B6 is something possible though
after B6 maybe Knight B3 if we go back
and then play C4 Knight D4 right it's a
it's a good square but after Knight A5
if we go back it's also possible simply
to play Rook V8 and then black sits and
wait what do you want to do with your
knight whether you're going to play C4
so you're ready to come back to B3 and
D4
and you say maths night is worth three
points Rook is worth five
white has a small Edge yeah the black
Rook tied down exactly like the White
Knight here so this is this is why if we
go back to H5 it's an interesting
position it looks like it's completely
drawish and there's no life right at the
same time it becomes very concrete
because
Nakamura had to make a decision do I
play A5 to stop Knight A5 and then I
allow G4 where I play H5 and I allow
Knight A5 right because I'm pretty sure
that the next move would be A5 yeah so I
agree that the probably white is going
to be playing Knight A5 in the next move
though I think B6 is just perfectly fine
for black
yeah just to show your idea on the board
there uh Judy King F2 most likely is met
by A5 and
yeah suddenly it's harder for this white
knight to get in maybe happy with white
you know after A5 yeah somehow looking
at maybe this one I want to trade
bishops get the white knight in but
it looks a bit strange there's some
danger under the waters A4
yeah I'll jump in
trying to provoke you forward to create
weaknesses oh I like this Clash of
styles I mean I I think it's just level
but I'm just looking at moves yeah
because I would I was happy to see that
Rook A5 would be my next move but of
course uh Bishop B5 is is a good point
there yeah I mean if if white just Waits
here for example suddenly black is for
Choice suddenly this is a huge weakness
White's night is terrible on the edge of
the board and things could start to turn
but uh yeah this is the current position
after H5 oh sorry after H5 here and uh
we do await Wesley to make a decision
Knight A5 on tap or maybe just King F2
or H4 is white if he wants a slower
build up but uh what about making crazy
move like B4
stop your A5
classy stuff it's not crazy at all uh
makes a lot of sense black spawns would
then be pretty much immobilized right
it's a very primitive way of thinking
it's just B4 to stop you playing A5
before I play A5
sorry very good all the B4 puns
yeah before actually makes a lot of
sense if Wesley's feeling ambitious
maybe that's one of the moves he could
choose because then Knight A5 doesn't go
away but is it really a vastly move
playing before that's so aggressive I
think so well it's space he he I kind of
see him as someone who likes to control
the game and control the nature and I he
definitely is a little bit Safety First
at times and he will be anticipating
H4 on the board
yeah it's not necessarily the best move
it just stops black from Gaining space
it kind of helps to fix a Pawn on a
light Square the same color as Black's
Bishop but this is what the top players
really hate right to give space
advantage and Initiative for the other
one you if there's any way you can avoid
that they avoid it yeah H4 G5 did not
look uh very good from the white side
yeah it's instructive even in an end
game they're still looking for space
normally you would think with pieces off
the board of space less relevant but
here yeah still fighting for squares
definitely and uh okay well this one's
still a lot to play for shall we zoom
out and have a look at the other games
yep let's check back in on some of the
games we haven't been to for a while I
see developments actually everywhere and
uh where do you want to go Ivanka I was
Prime okay there's a few games that I'm
kind of interested in the first one I
think we should visit is perhaps uh
alireza faruja and gukesh primarily
because yukash is uh broken out into the
center and it does mean that things do
get quite critical pretty quickly once
black has done this Pawn break yeah and
uh also in that clash between teenagers
both have kind of uh used up a lot of
time on the clock already we're only at
move 15 uh both players down to around
one minute twenty one minute 25 uh one
hours 20 sorry one hour 25 and this is
crazy this is the Italian game in a
nutshell it just always kind of livens
up at some point and it's about who's uh
more primed who's ready for that action
to happen look what happened
three phone it's gonna die a painful
death at some point it's gonna fall off
the board
but uh yeah I guess it's just a question
of how white eventually rounds up this
Pawn maybe it just takes quite too much
time later in the game and black will be
able to kind of strike in the center
strike on the king side
I mean is it also possible just to
forget about that pawn and just
concentrate in developing the forces and
then and then you know one in the end
game
Munch yeah or is that just wishful
thinking oh I like your thinking that
you're thinking about end games and
black does not want to think about end
games heavy such hold on A3 I believe
unless this phone becomes a queen in the
end game
I can hardly imagine or visualize that
yeah and the central tension that black
has just initiated uh maybe we jump in
with a couple of variations uh D5 has
just been played here and if white takes
this Pawn I guess the idea is to take
with the Knight
on D5 just uh to ensure that by
attacking this Pawn there's no time for
white to get greedy on E5 and this
change in Pawn structure is something
that you mentioned earlier today just uh
D5 is not always necessarily good for
black and let's say I just develop let's
say I just defend everything
yeah firstly I'm not sure if this is a
threat Knight takes E5 uh next move but
either way black can just play a move
like rookie eight and what do you make
of a position like this one
well it's a very dynamic position right
rookie eight
it's harder for hard to find a move with
white actually
I guess well probably you can just
develop Queen C2 bringing the Rook to D1
also sometimes uh well Knight F4 can be
some very unpleasant yes that's my like
red flag for initiating King side
attacks when the Queen and King are
disconnected from each other
yeah I would be really reluctant to go
into this with white uh I've got to be
honest and if white doesn't really want
to take on D5
then what else
maybe you just kind of keep the tension
maintain the tension just move your
queen but
if black has the center right now it
doesn't feel like you're too happy with
white yeah but the question is what's
the plan with black right you can also
develop with the bishop D2 for example
or I can go Queen C2 yeah
say queen C2 now rookie eight
let me see two
six just yeah more developing moves
yeah it's kind of a guessing game it's
like please break the tension no you
break the tension yeah yeah and of
course he takes D5 is always to consider
right to take he takes D5 and then you
take it with the Knight and I would want
to play C4 at some point
mm-hmm
with white uh with or without capturing
because this is sometimes during I think
without capturing is also interesting
yeah because I was looking at just kind
of a waiting move but where does black
put the queen for example if I put it on
a bad Square then maybe you break
forward immediately some ideas of uh C5
incoming and yeah if I just wait again
I'm not sure how then C4 C5 might come
like you say you might take then Bishop
C1 back oh yeah just to make sure you go
back with your rook and maths again
the bishop ties down a rook
one nil but only in moral terms but also
Bishop E3 can be considered sometimes
maybe trying to exchange those black
Square Bishops
yeah I must admit the one thing I'm
always terrified of with white and with
black in these Pawn structures where
there's so much attention is a move like
Queen C1 just uh hitting this Pawn but
also saying if you're not careful under
the right circumstances I might capture
on H6 I like it uh I've lost too many
games as a child when my opponent just
goes kind of Bishop D2 Queen C1 takes on
H6 and checkmates me just to show A
variation something like this I don't
think it works here because black has
too many pieces defensive pieces around
the king the black queen can simply come
over to challenge its counterpart but
yeah if white is given the time the
knights will come in and we could well
just see
Checkmate so just very tense and if we
go back to the current position what
else could farusha be thinking about
surely not D4 in a position like this uh
too explosive here too much to calculate
and what about the trade of Bishops is
that we should be three Bishop E3 just
just because I've noticed that far Asia
does like to do this but
um I would be skeptical about playing
this move just primarily because you
lose control over the F4 Square
but you know swings and roundabouts as
they say without your dark Square Bishop
you'll never take my A3 Pawn
that's what do you think David
Knight D2 and Knight B1 one day
oh you're ganging up on me now that poor
porn what has it ever done to you
yeah difficult position though for both
sides gotta say
really really it's very complex
yeah that game that I mentioned when I
played for Russia in the grand Swiss in
the Italian game I think he got down to
20 minutes after just 20 moves and it
was just a mad time scramble because we
had a very tense position like this one
and uh yeah it's just so hard to kind of
break the tension every move you have to
decide you have to calculate
and uh yeah he tends to thrive in those
types of situations but good cash I
quite like the way he's handled the
opening with black despite this Pawn
being on A3 when it comes to tension
have you noticed that you know players
can hold their nurse for x amount of
moves I mean like what do you think
there's the limit before someone cracks
maybe for sure will crack now and take
on D5 and release the tension it's hard
to say well it depends which side of the
tension you are if you are having a good
position and you have the tension that
you can you can hold it for a long time
right yeah yeah and uh it depends how
uncomfortable the situation is I believe
for black I mean he's very happy to hold
the tension playing rookie 8 Queen D6
Bishop D7 Bishop E6 Knight F4
and and just look for the moment the
optimal moment when it's uh it's the
best to give up the tension for white I
think it's more difficult in such a case
because you have to how should I play it
takes D5 is it black going to take on it
on the E4 is he going to play Bishop E6
so after I'm taking the pawn he's going
to take with the bishop already
I think this kind of tension it's more
difficult for white at this point so you
suspect that if anyone is going to crack
it will be far Asia
well I'm not sure I wouldn't say he will
crack but I'm saying that it's more
difficult for white side because I've
noticed when it comes to time troubles
player just is just through my years of
commenting players can kind of withstand
the tension maybe 20 moves or so and
then they crack this is like time travel
tension and then I I've noticed that
um that when you are playing in time
travel that people either simplify
because they can't handle the pressure
or they push Pawns
because they have to do something
okay yeah I've noticed this actually uh
maybe it's just kind of coincidence but
especially with younger players uh kind
of I'm talking about players who are
just starting out uh they see a trade
they'll go for a trade just because they
don't want to have to think about what
happens if the opponent does it on their
own terms and it often keeps in the
tension is the hardest thing to do just
sitting there and saying okay you take
me because it improves my position I'm
not going to take you and help improve
your position I just uh I've just
noticed this when talking to a kind of
novice players or players who are just
starting out their chess Journeys and
yeah I don't know what it is it's just
human nature I guess to want to have
action to do something uh yeah
procrastinating is not always a good
idea in chess but occasionally you have
to you just have to sit and hold tight
and improve your pieces uh before doing
anything to make sure they're ready for
the tactics later just start craving for
Simplicity I do like hikaru's motto
keep it simple it's stupid
but I obviously he's not talking to
calling himself stupid
yeah and uh let's Let The Players kind
of stew in this position uh it's a long
think right now over 10 minutes for uh
alarisa farouza and let's Zoom back out
and a couple of games that we haven't
been to for a while you know it's very
interesting what Mom and jar of position
is developing into
another position with full of tension
oh similar kind of central tension
Judith and uh we left this one a few
moves ago we will just do a quick action
replay of what has happened
and uh this is the current position
let's go back to the position here where
we left it black played Rook B8 so we
were talking maybe A6 B5 a very similar
idea Rook B8 supporting uh any porn
Avalanche with the Rook very very
logical E4 striking in the center met by
B5 uh Aryan not keen to trade off yet
and queen D2
not cracking that's for sure yes and
exactly we have again a nice Center
position who is going to be cracking or
giving up the tension right it's a big
big question because if white gives up
he takes D5 Knight D5 of course it's a
relief for black black is blockading the
isolated Pawn so it's very clear that
white wants to to activate his piece if
black takes captures on e4 Knight E4
already activating Knight C5 spot
and so another question is whether is
black going to push B4 forcing
uh right to capture on D5 for example or
also there's um another move that I
would kind of instinctively also think
about is the bishop coming out to G4 and
just pressuring the weak spot on D4
yeah just removing a Defender uh
indirectly attacking the spawn maybe we
jump in and show some very definitely
forcing or not forcing and the tension
is uh up to ariantari to relief fear he
spent eight minutes on this move we're
talking about for example two moves I
think at least the first you calculate
another thing that everyone at home I
think should be doing forcing moves
first so D takes E4 is one of the most
direct and white does have nice little
Pawn uh something we saw in the game
between Abdus Torah fangiri but this can
be blockaded by Black Knight the
downside is as Judith mentioned the
White Knight has a beautiful Outpost as
well on C5 if you ever kind of get this
Pawn as stepping forward later it could
become a real kind of uh Menace but in
this position I've for example I would
love to play with black Bishop E6 and
having the putting the bishop on D5 not
necessarily the Knight similar idea to
YouTube anchor just to maybe at least
hint that later you will capture this
Knight and uh kind of remove the
defender of this Pawn looks pretty it
looks pretty good actually
yeah well probably after Bishop E6
you're not necessarily playing ic5 but
next move is Bishop D5
whatever happens
yeah whatever happens and that's the
issue for white I'm really not liking
this bishop it's just a bit stuck uh the
white Bishop on E2 and if this bishop is
uh blocking the only open file the E
file then the white Rook struggled to
get in the game anytime white plays the
move A4 for example to try and break
down these pawns black will just answer
with A6 but then again after A6 already
Knight C5 now that's a different story
okay one another Bishop is also on E6
could you even
yeah this is also looks good
so maybe this could be one idea but I
think after a four maybe bishop D5 to
start with first hitting the Knight
forcing me to commit and then if you go
Knight C5 then I would think but I think
Bishop F3 and D4 is hanging yeah yeah
and uh and white doesn't have time to
take here because uh after 86b5 this is
a check and the White's Queen would drop
off
spoof yeah tactics seem to be working in
Black's favor here somehow so I wouldn't
actually blame Aryan for cracking as
we've been calling it and kind of
breaking the tension in the center this
looks good but also your move your
Banker Bishop G4 I guess the uh idea is
similar just to undermine this Pawn
and Judah I don't think white wants to
step forward yet because there could
still be problems with the pawn after
Knight to F5 followed by capturing then
suddenly the D4 is exposed
yeah really complicated position but it
feels like Aryan solved all of his uh
opening problems as black it's just
about whether he's equal or maybe even
more than that but it's also very
challenging when you have a very good
position you you didn't expect
necessarily that after uh move 13 or 14
you have a very good position with black
against mamajarov and then you have to
to decide to play B4 to take on e4 to
develop your piece to Bishop to G4 or E6
or you move with your queen or you go A5
or A6 as a prophylactical move so you
have a lot of options and then you have
to choose out of the money it's uh it's
also eating your time that's true it has
been eating its time I know it better
than anyone the number of times I spent
20 minutes on the move just because
there's Choice even though a quick
decision would have been uh just as
strong but let's allow Ariana a bit more
time to think he's just over the one
hour mark right now at a really tense
critical moment and let's Zoom back out
again and uh
yeah this is like a perfect moment
actually
to look at all the games and contemplate
and think about all the action that is
brewing nicely because it's time I think
to take a quick refresher and take a
pause and take a break
and uh well if we've witnessed a lot of
fine action so far and Don't Stray too
far because there will be a lot of Chess
excitement on the other side so see you
in a few moments
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki androsh
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as anishikiri and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level you're getting
started on the fundamentals you should
check out everyone's first chess
workbook maybe you want to stop letting
all those points slip away in the end
game 100 end games you must know is the
course for you
did you not notice your king was in
check and still can't figure out why the
pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
I really love watching games by top
female players and studying their games
in the past and I think that's like one
really cool thing that the test
Community could do more of I know my
friend Luciana is publishing a testable
course on some of the great games by the
early world champions veravan chick
rodengo and you can learn just as much
from these games as you can learn from
any game and yet it does provide
inspiration and like adds like depth to
our chess culture so I about 10 years
ago I published a book called play like
a girl with like tactics by female chess
players and actually redoing that book
and it's so much fun to just like kind
of like dig in and see some of the most
important tactical themes in chess decoy
in between move pins
double attacks and to look for like some
of the the best examples by top female
players so when you hear all these
discussions about women in jazz it's
great sometimes I'm just like wow you
should just like go study some music
games
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls in addition to stunning
geography Norway is home to the greatest
chess player who has ever lived Magnus
Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh dollar Raju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana two more long-time
Headliners seek to take their next turn
Atop A major tournament Wesley so and
Shakira Mamet yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field
who will come out on top will Carlson
run the table yet again or will someone
else usurp the throne this is Norway
chess
welcome back and we are back in Action
there in the playing venue as we see
Fabiana Carona with the white pieces
taking on Magnus Carlson
and as the players line up into that
middle game stage there have been some
developments happening in this game
yeah this game has changed it's only
been a couple of moves but uh we do see
Magnus has made a big decision which
could impact uh the rest of the game
he's decided okay not to go for that
line that we mentioned he's just
allowing Fabiano to continue development
so white will continue with the space
Advantage uh we loved White's Pawn
structure last we were here and it will
be up to Magnus later to uh find some
counter play as black to at least Force
Fabiano to think and let's just recap
the last couple of moves we left it in
this position black gave a check quit A5
this was blocked uh this check was
blocked with Knight to C3 and Knight to
B6 the clear plan is Knight to C4 he
wants at least one strong piece on this
C4 square and Fabiano Wow E takes F6 on
the last move I thought he would just
Castle get the white king to safety but
committal decision Judith
he takes F6 is always something that
black has to consider and especially
that after the Knight was moved from
these seven now Knight F6 is not
possible Right which is many times a
very good reaction after capturing so
the Knight comes to E4 now after Knight
B6 e takes F6 from this point the view
is a very logical decision
most likely black is not really
considering GTX F6 or that's what I'm
thinking so Bishop F6 would be the move
I would think also Rook F6 can be
considered so the bishop can go to B4
later on but of course the idea behind
Knight B6 is to reach out to C4 right
and provoke y to play B3 and but most
importantly to to disturb the bishop on
E3 to put pressure on B2 the bishop can
show up on B4 and this is why he takes
F6 is interesting because white wants to
know that is your Bishop going to be
standing on E7 as an option to play
Bishop B4 or which was played right now
uh Magnus did take with the bishop
because he wants to get the control uh
the square of the E5 Square where their
white wants to go Knight E5 at some
point that will be a big question but
now I think the first question for white
whether is he going to be allowing
Knight C4 for black is he going to play
B3 to stop that
or he just goes castling and then after
Knight C4 let's say going back with the
bishop right I mean it's definitely
definitely very appealing for white
because after all black does have a
backward Pawn on E6 that's a big Target
and
I see a lot of tempting plans for white
yeah which one uh which ones catch your
right let's jump into the position let's
show some variations Ivanka you see a
lot of tempting moves here yeah it's
either to stop that night jumping as a
dude it highlighted or because I don't
really think that much I'm not worried
about that night jumping in I was just
thinking of castling and then just
stepping back with the bishop on F2 and
then just uh doing
what
I think people do against the French
defense make them suffer right
yeah but the recording one
and uh you know have your eye line on
that E6 Pawn until the end of time
but I think black can go Bishop D7 and
black is really provoking white to play
B3 right to kick out that night because
it's it's very comfortably sitting there
especially if black has the time to play
Rook C8 before then all kind of jumping
would be possible so now I will go back
to D6 and true not jumping from F6 but
from D6 it's just as well it's gonna be
good to go to E4 or optionally also
sometimes Knight F5 can be also an ID
and now we can see that the queen on C1
really stands not optimally because Rook
C8 is coming so definitely white will
have to move out from the C file
um yeah still feels good for weight but
it's hard to know exactly what to aim
for right it is a very complex position
I think here in this French defense
because it looks like white has a clear
Advantage because of the E6 weakness
over there at the same time there are
weaknesses for white too so the C file
is very important counter chances for
black time to time even Bishop E8 Bishop
H5 or G6 can show up but also Knight E7
and the bishop can be also useful on B5
sometimes so there are a lot of
complexity in these positions I believe
and if fight goes Knight
E5 then already other questions appear
whether black is going to be capturing
it with a bishop and then Knight F5 but
I see right now that Knight E5 would
worry me most
from Blackhand
yeah 22 here queen queen D2 and then you
start doing my favorite thing in the
world it's just irresistible yes
G4 I live for this type of chess
and I cannot reign in my instincts any
longer so you're also in the G4 move
Club yes okay but only in the middle
game they're never in the opening it's
too wild for me then
yeah this is uh one variation and uh
just to show the alternative that we
mentioned would be to just clamp down uh
in the start position with B3 to render
this Black Knight a bit passive if it
can't jump into C4 then where is it
going that's the big question this Black
Knight actually gets in the way of the
queen as well uh a logical variation for
example would be Bishop D7 and castles
Rook C8 and suddenly there's some
counter play so this is similar to what
you showed that Judith uh it just
depends whether white can kind of get
out of the firing line quickly enough
because I would prefer to have this
position if White had a move or two more
just with the Black Knight on B6 really
stuck but I think on the other one just
not in time maybe instead of Castle
White can try to play A3 what do you
think and try to trap the queen
sneaky Rook C8 I guess the queen is
trapped the fun part starts B4 Tech
steaks thanks
takes takes takes takes takes and then
it'll be one wow
I don't think black's got enough here
Knight C4 I can jump but then now you
start kicking me back and yeah but
that's a problem for black if you cannot
sacrifice because then black is behind
in time yeah after A3 I don't want to
have to play the move Knight C8 but
maybe I have to and go for something
similar to what we showed but the knight
in D6 at least now my queen has some
breathing space some Retreat squares but
maybe this is the only only way to do it
for black
because B4 is not so advisable because
you move back with the queen and after
Knight D6 it's also Knight C4
yeah you give you take squares but you
give squares that's the problem in the
French defense uh so hard to weigh up
which squares to give and which ones to
go for uh yeah really complicated maybe
instead of Queen B6 I would rather go
back to d8 because after Queen B6 you
have to calculate Knight A4 Knight C5
also
yeah that's a very good point actually
suddenly white gets the knight in uh
Knight A4 C5 the other one E5
these nights as they say as the kids say
these days beautiful pieces wow no this
is too good to be true
yeah yeah this is not something position
you get against Magnus right you can win
a piece you can win many things but this
is not the kind of position he enters
this is the type of position that just
scares me away from the French defense
but uh either way it looks like
something like this would show up on the
board he would not play French defense
for another three years
uh B3 I think it's going to be seen uh
the fact that Fabian is pausing and just
as I say it yep he makes a move it is B3
on the board so very logical as we've
just explained keeping this Black Knight
passive for at least a few more moves
and Magnus has to try and untangle his
pieces long term black is a lot worse so
he still needs to play dynamically
energetically
and we saw this very tempting and very
promising idea of going A3 B4 but on a
human level
do you think it's
it's something that will be on his radar
because it does entail some risk and
obviously some calculation which we know
Fabiano is very good at
yeah I think it might also be on his
radar purely because uh black has
another plan of dropping back as Judith
mentioned and kind of going for some of
these weak Dart squares and the only way
to kind of stop the bishop annoying you
on some of these squares is to play A3
at some point so
um it kind of makes sense
to kind of firstly set up a one move
threat try and trap The Black Queen but
also I think it makes sense
strategically just to kind of keep your
opponent guessing uh you can always then
meet any tactics by stepping forward
with B4 and
yeah I think it'll be on the radar and
those are the type of moves you can find
either just by looking for your own
threats or by also thinking about how to
deal with the opponent's ideas
I found it
I played the E3 I'm sure Fabi is just
eager to play it's relaxed move but I
often say that a spectator sees
everything that's true because they have
the calmness and they're not vested and
of course you we have to remember the
clock times you know because the players
are not getting any time added until
move 41 in which case they get the 10
second increment per I have an idea
maybe black should be going Queen B4 now
let's jump in Queen B4 what's the sneaky
idea there dude at first you're
attacking this Pawn well yeah but that's
just a joke right you're going to
optimize your queen and put it to day
two yeah and after that I can go Bishop
D7 and then after A3 I just sneak back
with the queen to E7
we should point out Queen takes B3 is
not to be advised not really yeah so
Queen E7 as you mentioned
and you've harmonized your pieces maybe
this Black Knight can come back to D6
nice centralization
yeah you're still solid as black but
yeah you're solid but I know what you're
of course
you want G4 G5
that did cross my mind but I mean also
I'm just thinking boy it's still better
I mean white still has everything to
play for primarily that pawn on E6 which
is completely backward and as David
mentioned my favorite idea G4 G5
yeah it just feels like black again is
on the
suffering side of a draw
well I can try to play A5 possibly
trying to go A4 so if white goes A4 then
I have an outpost on B4 with the Knight
I'm not sure it's much obviously I have
to regroup my knight from B6 because
it's horribly placed
yeah that's one thing Nakamura has said
countless times I think about Fisher
random chess just the knight in B6 or G6
or G3 V3 is never well placed unless
they can jump forward
as expected and now we're we're
predicting the move A3
if you wait then you could get punished
along this C file I just don't know what
Magnus has in mind because there is not
much of an option right
yeah A3
what else I was looking at this
direction Queen D2 as well just to meet
this with Rook C1 but now I really am
scared of the bishop dropping back and
maybe utilizing these squares
so I think this is awesome yeah
we're predicting uh well I thought up to
that point and then suddenly we got a
prediction wrong so Rook C8 what is the
idea because now there's a big threat of
just jumping out the way with this
knight uh maybe Knight takes D4 and this
white knight is under Fire
What's Happening Here is it suddenly we
are thinking and we're speechless yeah
it's totally speechless he must have
something up his sleeve
big threats
A3 now what do you think
he's probably calculated this I was just
too lazy to calculate A3 Knight d4b4
you have um Rick takes it doesn't look
nice
do you have you've got nice too at the
end of it as well there's some checks
wow there's so many tactics in this
position we've all gone silent we're all
calculating
fabby's probably calculated this already
in his sleep but uh
Knight takes night I mean what happens
if I take this one
or it takes C3
hitting the queen Black's a piece up
temporarily Pawn takes yeah and Rook
takes here and I'll leave this one for
later
uh yeah no matter which one you're just
grabbing back the exchange yeah no
matter which way white takes they'll be
uh a bunch of simplifications and if we
do a quick count at the end black has
won a pawn in that little transition
so it doesn't feel like it can be this
uh such a key moment right now uh let's
go back to the game Rook C8
I mean it has to be played sorry White
Castle and now surely Rook C8 what else
move first think later it looks like one
of those uh situations
Magnus does not believe that Fabi should
have something in his mind
yeah for sure Fabi has something it's
just a question of what is it
Rook C8
it's a mystery right now coming
I'm struggling here big question
yeah
I I kind of peaked just now at the
computer just to kind of also try to
gauge what is it and it says after Rook
C8 you just play Queen E1 whoa and after
Knight D4 let's jump back into the
analysis Rook C8
wow that's not obvious using the square
that's vacated by White's King maybe
some tactics on this diagonal no no
tactics just uh just a simple chess
which is just you you target the
which way do we take now take with the
bishop
and after a bunch of Trades black can
cash in on this Square in C3
yeah but at the very end and you take on
E6 up and is it a big deal no it says
small Advantage for white tiny Advantage
for white
wow I guess this bishop uh is going to
be superior than this Black Knight black
has a weak isolated Pawn in the center
but well let's say queen takes E1 Rook
E1 Bishop E6 takes Rook F6
white will have the better structure but
black is going to have an active Rook
well it's nice for white
if Magnus was white here I would say it
was winning
no that's a puppy but here I would say
just just Advantage white not winning
yet
yeah what a what a line yeah
Queen to E1 in this position if Rook C8
I'm just surprised that Fabia just
simply castling
yeah and allowing all this
he has spent almost an hour on the clock
we're at move 17 so he must have
foreseen this he but just the incredible
awareness to
even look in this direction to even kind
of keep your eyes open to tactics after
Rook C8 it looks so scary for white on
the board it's on the board and how
quickly do you think Fabi is going to
play this Queenie one move
is this the only actually I think he has
no other choice right
yeah all the tactics we showed were
looking favorable for black black was
winning a pawn in most of those lines
yeah I mean something is really going
wrong with this screen on C1 this is the
only Queen which we are debating all the
whole time right in the opening of Fabi
what he played the computer is saying
that there is another move it's weird
it's like put your queen on B2 because
I'm like I thought about that and after
Knight D4 and after Knight D4 you just
capture once with the Knights right and
then this is the kind of sneaky point
this is working C3 you go Queen F2 and
you say that's nice sensation that's
nice that's that's the this I like this
I would be happy with why
earlier Ivanka you asked about how human
this uh A3 was but this is difficult
once you find it it looks beautiful
you've got some tactics here you're
gonna hit back the black queen and the
B6 Knight basically that is the price
yeah one bad piece makes the position
bad but yeah this is difficult I think
Queen B2 and then kind of swinging the
queen across no it's not the end of the
world for black okay I understand that
we don't want to go Knight A8 I mean you
might have to if you have to you have to
right
hmm
now in the corner
don't advise it
don't try it at home don't have a rhyme
for that one but uh definitely don't try
it at home I guess it's coming back to
life via C7 but uh either way and after
Queen B2 is there any other option for
black which
can be played oh sorry after queen beat
it
I mean D2 is on the board win D2 they're
probably the same idea ah
clever clever stuff Fabiano he's so good
knight takes D4 we will see most likely
oh wow this is a blunder ah of course
because now we take with a bishop and ah
simple as that simple as that Queen
takes night not possible
C3 yeah and B4 The Black Queen cannot
defend both her Knight and her Rook uh
for example Queen A3 defending the Rook
drops the night we've been all uh
talking about for the rest of this game
for the earlier part Queen takes B6
solving things far more simply than we
were here in the studio Queen D2 really
nice move and also setting up tricks
potentially against the black queen
along this diagonal this type of tension
with Queens on D2 Queens on A5 from the
Sicilian from all brushes of openings uh
often very uncomfortable
problems have been solved well let's say
97 and Knight F5 is kind of a logical
way of continuing right
just to show the type of tactic that I
was mentioning here Knight E4 is
possible uh just to kind of open up this
tension against the Queen the black
queen undefended so if quintix Queen you
can flick in Knight takes F6 check I'm
not sure whether you want to do this and
now you could just simply capture you've
improved the Blackboard structure but
you've got the Queen's off got the
bishop pair still this Knight on B6 is
quite annoying for black
that's for sure
I mean white white is better yeah white
has the advantage it's just about how
much and let's go back to the position
it looks like Fabi has found a really
nice way of stabilizing and back to
Magnus he's throwing the move back uh
now pressure on the Norwegian to find
something
yeah roughly in time wise they are more
or less the same
would you say that a little bit pushed
for time I mean it's only move 17 and
they've already burnt an hour on the
clock that is not the part of the game
which we'll decide so far it's
everything will decide on the board I
guess is the time is not it's irrelevant
irrelevant for the moment but uh
I would definitely play it with the
right side
stable might stabilize the position of
the electric C1 weakness on E5
the Knight on B6 is is really giving a
hard time for black especially after
Rook C8 right he cannot go back Knight
C8 maybe in the previous move it could
be an option to regroup the Knight first
if this is a leading over Rook C8 then
maybe that would make a better option
for black
yeah just feels like it's too late now
for Magnus to go for that maneuver maybe
between A3 I mean after all a little bit
blockade there
what do you think Queen A3
I was thinking Queen A3 as well and also
maybe get the queen ready to jump to the
king side if she's needed there
defensively
the queen a395
it looks like white has an easy play
yeah plenty of kind of obvious moves for
white not many obvious moves for black
95 is coming you can just kind of set up
with Rook uh see one first rookie one
just lots of useful moves Bishop H3
useful move I have an idea I have this
Roland chess I call it my Golden Rule
when your king is in problems or when
you're in problems full stop you try and
trade off Queens so using that logic I'm
like maybe you can put your knight on E7
on A7 yeah so it can jump to B5 and jump
in trade off Queens because the end game
isn't actually going to be that bad for
black
but the problem is Rook C1 and you
cannot go Knight B5 because of Knight D5
tactics Knight D5 yeah yes
that is true check and pulling up for
white yes no no no no I was actually
going to point out Knight beat Knight D5
on many occasion but it wasn't possible
because the queen was having some
connection with the D5 point so yes yeah
so Knight A7 you can strike that one off
your list doesn't work
yeah that's why maybe Queen A3 would be
a logical move here just because uh you
can never really move this Knight away
without allowing any tactics yeah uh
along this diagonal so just get out of
Dodge get out of the way first makes a
lot of sense Queen to A3 and uh yeah
think later about how to proceed either
swing the queen back or maybe bring the
Knight forward still lots of ideas still
very rich impossibilities for these two
players should we go check out some of
the other actions let's zoom out of this
one uh this is the current position
after going to go to alireza what do you
think let's go there indeed because
there are some
attention was broken oh who cracked and
sand it
nobody could stand
yeah I feel guilty about how much joy we
get out of that but of course the two
players give us our small Pleasures
David I mean they're young they are just
in the beginning of their top career
look at that and take a look at that
we do have like an exclamation No
exclamation mark a question mark on
White's last move says it's a mistake
question mark with the question why is
it bad
is it Queen G's Queen D6 or just some
sacrifice already taken Queen H4
yeah maybe there was something better
that's uh I think that's another
potential issue here we do see uh kind
of the definitions Behind These double
exclamation marks these uh kind of
question marks the x's and everything
and this one it made the position worse
but doesn't necessarily mean it's a bad
move and it's on its own I don't see any
tactical refutations yeah I may go back
for a few moves there and who gave up
the tension first yes so let's go back
to the position we left it uh earlier we
were analyzing the position after black
had played Pawn to D5 and uh actually it
was farugia with white to crack and uh
take on D5 we predicted Knight takes D5
hitting this Pawn of course Bishop D2
natural reaction Bishop E6 and the first
kind of spicy fruity move that I see
Knight to H5 uh in this position guarded
against that idea I think you both
mentioned it of the Black Knight landing
on F4 now the White Knight would simply
be able to capture that piece and also
some tactics against the black king
black drop back Bishop C7 very natural
defending the spawn and after D4 he
takes D4 this is the question mark move
the the mistake Knight takes D4 it looks
extremely natural Judith
maybe rookie 6 was possible don't you
think so wow wow an exchange Rook takes
E6 and what would the idea be after I
take back you have some materials
in G4 but maybe there is no need for
something like that Queen D6 yeah I
guess the problem is black defense would
happen became over optimistic I believe
yeah if you could get quenchy for it now
without allowing Queen H2 then a
beautiful compensation for white but
black uh does have this counter attack
so but at some point you know black has
to be careful on Queen C1 kind of moves
instead of taking on E6 when Knight D4
was played
so instead of Knight takes D4 yeah some
wow Quincy one probably that's
exaggerating again but it's it's a real
threat sometimes yeah maybe not in this
position but definitely later on to
sacrifice here and okay so Knight D4
good question why is it a question mark
right
wow okay I've been a bit naughty there
and I've checked uh so here farouza
could have already pounced it's your
idea dude just a different order Bishop
takes H6
wow okay we can't blame him for not
playing this or not spotting it it just
what is the concept Queen D2 Queen C1
I'm assuming oh just Queen takes D4
oh wait that's a big hole
oh that was nice huge mess oops and this
is just completely winning for black the
problem is you cannot push your Pawn uh
to F6 to block because you drop your
Bishop on E6 and white is a pawn up with
the attack you cannot block with any
pieces everything is covered the E5
Square F6 square is covered for white
this is just gonna end in Checkmate or
material gain so what about Bishop H6 uh
you cannot take on H6
so how about taking C3 or something
hitting the White Queen but now just 22
or queen C1 yeah yeah
one of these squares and you can never
ever take my Bishop you can not touch
that because again checkmate
okay I said we can't blame him for not
finding that but maybe
after playing Knight H5 it's it is an
option to
Discover it right because your your way
of thinking already it's there to
where's the king that's that's right but
I mean it's it's difficult I think it's
very difficult to kind of criticize far
Asia making such a natural move because
I'm pretty sure the hand just went
Knight takes Knight takes Pawn natural
stuff don't need to calculate anymore
but yeah this is why it's so important
to be on the lookout for every single
check capture threat and do as my good
old dad says sit on your hands
yeah it's ferocious style as well it's
right up his street I'm I've alluded to
it a couple of times when I played him
in the Italian game and uh he beat me
there he also sacrificed on H6 when I
thought it wasn't possible so he's
looking in that direction all the time
uh he also had a night on H5 in that
game uh so it's basically the similar
pattern and
this is like a trademark attack that
faruga has
it looks that way and just executing
that attack it feels like a missed trick
Bishop takes H6 but let's catch up with
the game instead Knight takes D4
happened uh question mark not just
because it's a bad move but because it
missed an even better one uh hitting
this bishop on E6 this was dealt with uh
by Queen D6 threatening a counter-attack
the queen H2 slide would potentially be
devastating for the white king and
farusha blocks that with his Knight so
no more attack now against the black
king he drops back he's kind of walked
into a self-pin on this diagonal but I
guess he's hoping later to improve that
night maybe onto F5 maybe onto E4 and
now it's black turn to play Knight age
Symmetry and go some H3
[Laughter]
now that would be Karma wouldn't it
nobody's not so good because right
actually threatens to take on E6 and
queen G4 yeah
is this a threat then Knight takes E6
strategically yes you get the bishop
pair you've wrecked the black porn
structure but it does open up the black
Rook
uh in terms of attacking uh prospects
there for black
if fit is a threat then either we have
to defend against it we have to maybe
guard it with our Rook or drop back or
what about yeah Bishop D7
yeah we can drop back with our Bishop
those two moves look healthy enough
what's White's next move
is it uh Queen F3 Queen F3 Queen H5
Queen somewhere yeah Queen H5 stop
Knight H4
but Knight F4 these Knights they're so
pesky and tricky and this night's coming
in this night's coming in
oh the Italian trust me it's the opening
I hate the most it's so complicated it
seems so innocent right yeah and after
some D5 and some action happens in the
center then it's just unexpectedly
complicated there's always so much
poison later because it's so tense there
are so few peace trades at an early
stage yeah that's what um
one of my first trainers said to me
about the Italian and the Royal Lopez
and said the reason you're struggling
with these type of positions is that
because you can't handle the tension of
four minor pieces being on the board for
you for you there's too little space so
he said find an opening where you make
that trade
simplify and then you're in the element
I thought that was good advice
genius advice if you know your
weaknesses you can uh avoid them you can
fight against them
but maybe it's not genius to announce it
to the world
all your future opponents will be
listening right now Ivanka
Italian game keep all my minor pieces on
the board
yeah this position it looks so
symmetrical as well that's uh the
deceptive part of the Italian game the
pawn structure there's some small kind
of nuances there especially the apron
kind of in the end game it might all
revolve around that one but
now for now with all the pieces on the
board it's so hard to come up with
constructive moves I think fearuza also
missed this opportunity playing Bishop
86 because first of all it was given to
him by the last move of black it's very
typical so it was not a threat but it
was given the opportunity and the other
thing is that first of all he was
spending quite a lot of time up to this
point an hour already and he felt that
he just feels very comfortable having
the Knight on D4 attacking putting
pressure on the bishop on E6
and he was happy with his position I
guess and he was not looking for more
than that and he didn't think that there
is something very special opportunity
was given
yeah and I I just checked actually and
uh that moment where he had that
potentially winning tactic he spent only
26 seconds so he didn't really uh start
calculating like you say Judith uh
something changed and he didn't really
notice the change it's so easy to do
this is a question right when we're so
far be thinking go and see takes D4
capturing back and I was complaining
that some people would just simply take
it back without thinking any second or a
minute wasting it and look at here that
he he did that and uh
this was the problem
58 the Young Generation they don't care
about Pawn structure
they just want to end the game with
Checkmate they just want to attack he
brings another piece into the uh action
is there any threats
I don't think immediately Bishop C8 yeah
I think that that's the main idea if
you're not going to capturing my Bishop
then I escape with the CA and it's a
much better place on C8 than D7 suddenly
you have Harmony between your pieces
and yeah let's jump in to show what will
happen if white does go for the
Strategic uh or the at least the
strategically desirable movement takes
on E6 Knight takes E6 black is left with
shattered pawns this E6 Pawn just like
in the Magnus game a long-term weakness
but suddenly this line is opened this
line is opened I'm seeing some potential
sacrifices on F2 uh just to undermine
this Knight
how does white keep everything intact
maybe it's just a really scary position
it
Dairy but I mean you
need to reinforce protection of the
Knight on G3 and maybe you can just go
just before unless that something
like E5 comes in
you're kicking me around with those
nights but okay you can move the queen
but where we're running out of squares
well to E2 possibly because it's very
important that the main defensive idea
for black is to have the diagonal of
Queen on D6 and Bishop on C7 if the
white knight could be possibly jump to
E4 then practically Black's position
would be hopeless right yeah for example
like this then it's then it's over
uh so this is the key defensive and
contemplate element for black to keep
the bishop there and the and the Queen
it gets very sharp though I mean for
example if I jump in let's say I just
play Knight F4 attacking your queen
okay evaluation bar hates it and uh I
guess it's actually at the end right
yeah if black had one more move you
could line up an attack but yep suddenly
things are falling on this line on this
diagonal
yeah difficult position uh to judge I've
got to say and it will take courage to
take this to take this bishop because
you open up blacks Rooks but that's the
type of decision for Russia will make
and it's very interesting for black for
example that after Knight E6 after xe6
the D5 Knight is also an essential
Defender and attacker at the same time
right because he's blocking the Bishop
from B3 at the same time if white has to
be play he has to play C4 that's already
a different story and only then you move
away with your knight then already the
bishop is blocked
yeah true this bishop unparalleled but I
would also think sorry that maybe Rook
F2 can be sometimes yeah big threat
potentially
if uh for example I play Bishop C2 I
don't know attack your knight then bang
Rook takes F2 looks like potentially
winning tactics
it's not a joke
yes with some cooperation it's a killer
yeah I think there's now the time to
rewind and say that didn't work that
definitely doesn't work don't you don't
enjoy it so much
this is the type of thing that will make
ferocious see ghosts though like I would
be sitting at the board I see this
variation and I'm like okay I I'm scared
I need to escape and I wouldn't I think
capture this bishop but if you don't
take this bishop in the original
position
you're not going to be better with
weight especially Judah as you mentioned
uh what's a useful waiting move I don't
even see one but if Black's Bishop does
escape then it's only black and he'd be
uh who can be better really
it's hard to believe not that it's it's
not good to take on E6
I mean I think I would go to taken D6
and then somehow to put my queen
somewhere some somewhere somehow I don't
know Queenie too
Queenie two there's some hits on F4
one of the knights jumping in
gets complicated I'm also looking at
Rook takes F2 not sure that works
pretty difficult position maybe like
Ivanka said in G4 maybe Queen G4 first
to kind of uh lure the Black Knight
forward to E5 where it actually blocks
this diagonal and suddenly just drop it
sacrifice on E5
wow in this National key one instead of
winning too yeah
looks uh attempting the computer doesn't
hate it that much
yeah the black queen uh lacking squares
I guess I dropped back but if which way
yeah if you travel back to F6 you're
gonna
I was going to say you're going to get
kicked around a little bit but you're
not actually yeah if uh you attack my
queen now and defend F2 at the same time
I can offer trade of queens and you have
sacrificed materialist whites this is
too bad yeah so close but uh not quite
well I think he should go for it I think
he we want to see him take on E6 at
least it might backfire but it also
might be really good for white long term
that's the ambitious movement alirez's
middle name is ambitious so uh yeah
that's what we expect to see
two here
C2 is Knight B4 a move
Optics tactics tactics
wow so let's see Knight takes B4
attacking the White Queen firstly I'm
looking at this oh whoops not that one
I'm looking at taking here
G6 Queen G6 and then uh after ponte's
Queen Rook takes Bishop green juice oh
wow the evaluation part doesn't move it
looks good for white Rook takes E6
high five David wow we've been doing our
tactics
lunch and dinner I provoked you to make
this amazing move I never wake up early
enough for breakfast just tactics for
lunch and dinner that's uh that's it but
yeah I think here the black queen has to
give herself back up uh kind of back for
the material and white emerges okay so
if Knight B4 is not possible then maybe
Queen C2 and Rudy one yeah maybe that's
the safe approach uh in contrast in 1966
E6 which is uh extremely risky yeah as
you say fructue one comes white is solid
so let's say Bishop C8
let's say Rook D1
how many pieces uh are stacked up here
it's just so much tension on the default
Cafe
but somehow it looks like a nice
position for black
yeah feels healthy now right somehow it
seems to be a little bit more
more danger for White having the G3
Knight tied down yeah this tension just
feels like it suits Black I'm really
tempted to just kind of go Pawn hunting
now but I know I'll get checkmated along
the way while I go grab that one
uh that's uh yeah very optimistic yeah
very optimistic and I don't like
completely one and night before after
all yeah if you also put your queen so
far away from the action I mean doesn't
black also have moves like H5 H4 I don't
think you could put Knight on F1 no
checkmate
but an instructive pattern to remember
just in case uh black ever needs to
break through uh this night long term
yeah let's uh give farusha some time I
think we're predicting Knight takes E6
very controversial or queen to C2 if
he's feeling in a safe mood but either
way long think and what's he gonna go
for big question Let's uh maybe zoom out
of this one Let's uh check out some of
the other games which ones have been
developing that yeah and uh let's
definitely have a quick look at the
bird's eye view but I think it's time to
do a break just to recharge our
batteries for a little while before the
real excitement happens and of course we
do have to mention that there is a
wonderful opportunity cupping coming up
because do you love following chess.com
events and want to join the team are you
a passionate chess fan with experience
in organizing events and tournaments you
might be exactly the person we are
looking for to come on board as an
events coordinator use exclamation mark
apply in chat or go to go.chess.com
forward slash events underscore
coordinator underscore apply to submit
your application now
wonderful opportunity there and it is
time for a quick break on our end and
Don't Stray too far because there's more
chess excitement lined up
see you on the other side
today we're going to go down into the
New York City subway set up a table on
the subway platform and see if we get
some strangers waiting for their trains
to play chess with us
[Music]
sounds like he knows what he's doing a
little bit
[Music]
don't worry I'm not that good yeah
you're just out here playing chess not
that good got the chess.com app
you ever play on your phone oh yeah you
said he barely played I'm a teacher what
do you teach chess I'm just kidding
self-defense
stay sane I used to do a lot of
meditation take medication
what's like lesson 101 of self-defense
one what are you listening to right now
train
Sean Paul Ed Sheeran what is the meaning
of life it's funny because like what I'm
doing I feel like doesn't align with my
philosophy on what the meaning of life
is but it's like obviously spend as much
time with family as possible the best
person you can be get closer to God not
to be evil to each other
good game thanks for playing good games
I'll see you in a self-defense class
enjoy Harry Styles
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back and I hope you're refreshed
and ready after that short pause and
here you can see two American legends of
the game Wesley so playing with the
white pieces against Hikaru Nakamura old
friend and old rival and they are
playing in a game which looks quite
level I have to say and
this brings us to the question about are
we likely to see an Armageddon oh yeah
we are getting close to it I believe
yeah I think we'll see at least one or
two armageddings this round and this
game looks like the most likely
candidate so far
um the one maybe big difference though
is that Wesley so has been far slower
than his opponent down at 35 minutes
we're already having invested an hour
and a half up to this point and that
brings us nicely on to this question
from salandaphor he says would Hikaru
provoke an Armageddon Hikaru with the
black pieces and let's remind ourselves
of the rules of Armageddon white will
start with 10 minutes black will start
with seven minutes and there will be an
increment of one second it's not that
much after move 40.
yeah who would be the favorite in a
clash between these two I would normally
say Nakamura even if he's black but it
must be close right well that's the rule
right that whatever the classical game
set off was who played with white it's
going to be continuation in the R Market
on to play with the white pieces so it's
not doing of lots this is important to
know I think because the players are
aware of it and I'm not sure all the
players believe that it's Advantage for
white
to play the Armageddon because there
there is always a debate whether is it
better with white the three extra minute
is it really such a huge advantage
but there is a draw Advantage for black
right yeah so I think it's very tricky
this time control and Armageddon but I
think generally the statistics shows
that it favors white in Norway chess if
favors White
absolutely historically right yeah
it is really weird because we saw in
other events that players have been
vying for the black pieces but I've seen
our online chess when it's five minutes
against four minutes and the players are
super fast if you forget it if you play
with white you we've won basically
yeah and on the Champions chess tour
this season we have Armageddon where the
players bid and often one side starts
with 15 the other side starts with eight
and even there black is holding their
own so it's crazy the difference between
kind of mouse speed you can play 100
moves in eight minutes online with a
mouse but physically over the board
even with the one second increment it's
going to be uh crazy it's going to be
wild and we saw yesterday some of the
players losing on time even though we
they have a two second increment so yeah
I'm not so sure I would normally say uh
Hikaru is the big favorite there but
yeah it's uh it's gonna be touch and go
it's just about who can kind of maybe
get their type of opening if we get to
that stage but meanwhile uh there have
been a couple of moves which make me
think that we're not going to see a draw
yet black has pushed a pawn to C6 and
Wesley's just retreated with a knight uh
with his Knight and what do we make of
this uh Judith who would you choose here
and why
well I believe that
it's pretty balanced the
the if I was played with white I would
have the plan to play G4 maybe at some
point
or I don't know if black wants to go
Knight F5 but Knight F5 for now is not
so advisable I believe because of Rook
F4 and then either black has to go back
or after G6 I would be able to play G4
so it's not so easy to to locate the H6
Knight to somewhere where it's better
right
so here I think I would rather be with
the right side and is there any point
for white actually oh it's black to
place I'm sorry because I was thinking
what is probably going to go Knight A4
and force The Rook to a silly Square oh
wow yeah could be a potential hidden
threat there if black isn't too careful
uh as you mentioned a silly Square
Knight A4 might be met with uh Rook to
A6 and
nobody wants a rook on A6 ever my
question is where what do you think
about rookie 8 what is that kind of
position who does it favor to exchange
the Rooks yeah maybe we have to jump in
with some variations here because this
one it's either very good and we'll lock
down the position as a draw but uh it
could backfire somehow
what do you think about Rook F4 just
putting on cold that night on H6 and
then you want G4 G5 well I'm afraid you
start knowing me better yeah it's not
the first time we've seen G4 today
yeah here it makes a lot of sense you're
playing against one bad piece uh Knights
on the rim are damn
Ed
something something I can't remember the
German phrase let's bring a book Khan
German phrase there but it's all about
Knights being bad on the side of the
board and yeah this is the worst place
piece for sure yeah maybe Judith this is
strong for weight right and you also
have after G4 G5 like I'm running with
your Visions Judith I'm like yeah all
systems go because you can actually
then once you've kicked the Knight away
from H6 you can actually control the
fifth row Fifth Line yeah like I was
thinking maybe black can go F6 with the
idea of Knight F7
uh-huh
yeah actually that looks uh maybe like
the
I'm not sure the only way but the best
way to solve the problem of this Knight
now G4 G5 loses its sting
but some weak squares potentially if
White Knight can ever land on E6
this would be a dream yeah because now
G4 is not possible right because of
blacks playing G5 aha nice I mean h
takes G4 and G5 yeah
and now don't get greedy you will walk
into a night fork and white would be in
trouble
that would be a big whoopsie moment you
don't want to allow that
um
interesting
but how it kind of like moves such as
Pawn takes porn
and then and then I want to go C5 oh you
did you are speaking my language so in
sync
do you want to swing and go for this
point actually yeah I don't think black
should get tempted to take on C5 you
might have won a pawn temporarily but
um this one is going to be safe yeah
okay 894 right that's that's it
and long-term huge Advantage for white
due to Black's shattered pawns on the
queen side also Rook C4 is interesting
instead of Knight E4 we have the Rook on
the fifth yeah
yeah really nice move there just swing
and all sorts of targets on the fifth
rank so after C5 the move I want to play
is D5 but I do it reluctantly
before anyway okay four yeah yeah and
you're just gonna win a pawn right yep
B4
pin and you win this a pawn will drop
don't think black has enough
compensation you have a nice structure
long term nice protective passport but
Knights are notoriously bad against
these for exponents and yeah I don't
think black is going to be too happy
here
yeah there are some practical
inconveniences for black at this point
if you go back what is the at the on the
board
yeah what to play
I'm kind of attracted to a move like G6
initially but then I do foresee maybe
the white Knights somehow eventually
kind of getting into F6
I know I I really do think despite the
evaluation bar saying it's roughly level
despite Nakamura being half an hour up
on the clock it's slightly tricky for
him
uh I would definitely pick white too it
feels like you're far more flexible to
kind of initiate stuff as uh Ivanka
mentioned D6 C6 and throwing C5 in some
Knight A4 plans questions can I go
Knight G8
all the way home well sometimes you have
to go back together
yeah maybe Knight G8 just to come back
into the game either via F6 or E7 yeah
first I thought to come from F6 to put
pressure on D5 also but
but can you still do your plan of going
G4 Knight F6 and then you just sit on
the fourth row because that seems to be
and I just wanted to D5
ah ah maybe I can flick in this move
though
it's immediate movement yes yes but what
about taking first on G4 and after that
taking on D5
will that make a difference take or not
and if I step forward
I just wanted to get here at any cost
94 we go into a really complicated Rook
end game so good yeah white has all the
targets outside past Pawn
yep
it's not that easy for Hikaru actually
not that straightforward draw that we
had
initially thought it would be well maybe
G4 Knight E7 what do you think about
that Knight G8 g497
yeah I think this might be a cleaner
path and again if I ever take this one
then later The Rook will h8 I have
never mind
yeah the Black Knight has a beautiful
Square as well on F5 if it can get there
rookie 8 is on the board of Nike big
decision though we didn't discuss
rookies uh and just this Rook trade uh
this one as well looks a bit dangerous
to me so this comes Rook F4 right yeah
not the exchange itself
working for the more ambitious of the
two if Wesley really really wants to win
he'll say we'll see Rook f4 on the board
Rook takes E8 uh safe but maybe nothing
to do there no winning chances
yes because after rookie 8 King gate
Knight F5 cannot be stopped
that would put great pressure on the
phone on H4
yeah this is true if I could somehow get
my king to F4 and play G4 then I'd be
very confident with white but yeah
that's a good idea yeah just Knight F5
one movement and what about if you just
forget about that pawn on H4 because
there's still a lot of stuff to be said
for instance Pawn takes porn
so I'm just looking at forcing ways and
then now C5
okay let's say I don't get tempted to
teach yeah I was kind of hoping that you
would but and then I wanted to maneuver
for some reason my knight was getting to
attack your Pawn on A5 but now I can see
it's just not easy to reach that
for some reason I had like my night
arriving on B3 but I can see there's a
pawn there yeah
and not quite quick enough to get to D4
uh again if you had one more move to sit
on D4 you might be doing very well but
black is in time with Knight F5 to cover
that square and to hit on H4 so it looks
like a good move from Nakamura if the
Rooks come off uh looks like a very
healthy position there for black but the
key question remains will Wesley keep
the tension Rook F4 the only winning try
it feels like or take on C6 first and
then Rook C Rook F4 yeah something in
conjunction with Rook F4 also possible
to take on C6 and Rook D4 by the way
take and Rook D4 but then you allow the
Knight to Spring to F5 and then Rook F4
oh tricky tricky and having in mind to
play G4 later I'm not sure it's so good
but it's an idea
yeah so uh either way we're expecting
him to keep the Rooks on or hoping for
Wesley to keep the Rooks on and uh yeah
we'll check back in on this one later
you can see on the camera Nakamura is
away normally a show of confidence and
Wesley kind of staring off uh into the
distance for a second he's less certain
about his winning chances than yeah
we're back at the bird's eye view now
where shall we go there are developments
all over the place
um we we haven't visited
um nordebec Abdul satoroff against Anish
giri yeah quite a while this one has
become crazy if I'm not mistaken yes and
it's a variation in the Breakthrough
that we were discussing yeah
let's jump in there we see uh I'm just a
Turf with the white pieces we had this
isolated Queen's Pawn uh via the Queen's
Gambit declined early in the game and
let's just backtrack a few moves the
position was looking relatively quiet
just maybe three or four moves ago
around here white played Queen to A4
though creating a lot of tension uh
Black's Knight retreated and Knight to
D7 was the initiation of chaos on the
board all sorts of tactics this night
hitting the Knight and F6 hitting the
bishop of course but more importantly
hitting the Rook on f8 so this Knight
had to be eliminated and suddenly
Black's Rook found itself trapped and uh
Judah you mentioned that black had a
safety first move and he could have
probably just forced a very safe
position with uh the move Bishop to C6
immediately trading off this bishop and
here we would have most likely seen a
move such as D5 oh sorry Queen takes and
such as D5 coming in the near future
maybe even immediately Yes actually the
five maybe is kind of an unpleasant move
because after he takes d590 5 is
possible though Rook E6 seems to be not
too dangerous for black but there is
something very interesting is cooking
over there the way the game
the game continuation yeah so instead of
going for an equal position like this
one and he showed his ambition instead
of uh playing Bishop C6 he first took on
G3 a sacrifice and uh after his Rook was
captured now he plays the move Bishop to
C6 just for a second I would like to
highlight that instead of Bishop C8 it's
not really possible to take back H takes
G3 because then simply Rook C7 right and
black is getting a very nice position
beautiful keeping on the C file
controlling the D5 Square having the B7
Bishop on the diagonal so this is why
this is a critical line which is
happening on the game yeah this looks
great for black you can uh plant a
knight into the center there but instead
Bishop 68 did happen um Bishop C6 we see
an exclamation mark an exclamation point
here showing the best move for black and
they're on their move yeah otherwise you
would lose material otherwise you would
emerge an exchange down Rook for Bishop
so first you gain time against the White
Queen and you have to be really careful
where you put her in the break when I
was discussing with this with Judah my
first instinct was take this Pawn but
now the Knight can drop back whoops and
you gain Tempo you gain an important
Tempo against the White Queen and you
save your Bishop you'll merge with extra
material there as black so where to put
this uh this lady
the question is where to go with the
queen to B4 it's not possible because
then Bishop D6 intermediate move and
then the bishop is taken so Queen B3 C2
or D1
those are the alternative uh moves
there's also you can block the attack
with Knight B5
although that might be a mistake because
of Queen D5 when D5 looks uh quite scary
at first Rook C6 must be the only move
yeah
wow this is crazy this piece is all over
the board which one do we take and now I
guess we take this with the Knight
oh computer hits that one yeah because
Bishop B7 seems to be unpleasant so
maybe Queen takes
if we go back Queen takes C6 and
yeah it looks feels like Black's doing
well at least because this is pinned now
this bishop will drop in return for
Black's bishop and most likely isolated
Pawn after Knight B5 maybe it's also
possible just to take Queen takes C8 and
after that if white is taking the bishop
then Queen D7
or do you have some Knight A7 stuff yeah
the question is Knight takes A7 here I
really want to flick in this move Bishop
takes H2 just because I can
uh just now King takes I can move my
queen out of the line of fire with the
check and next move I win your queen
but uh if I move the king
more questions
oh wow this is complicated no but black
has two pieces for The Rook right Bishop
A4 so uh black is just better ah yeah of
course I can't do simple maths here and
we can just take and black has yeah yeah
I also got confused that there's too
many pieces were taken by black
blacks two pieces of far superior to the
white Rook okay so after Queen C8 you
have to take back the bishop right after
Knight B5 Queen C8
now you wanted Queen D7 Queen D7 yes
and that forces me
I guess to take on C6 well it seems like
that's the only move and it's it's
roughly equal yeah but how is this
position Rook takes Bishop sorry Rook
takes Bishop probably in C6 is the best
if you get Queen C6 96 987
put that on the board
wow all sorts of pins there's a pin in
this direction this time and black
emerges a pawn down probably still
holdable but you don't want to suffer
here yeah but okay why to give up a pawn
if we don't have to right
but the A7 Pawn is going to fall no
matter what
in that position not not in uh if you
capture with the queen you can actually
go
Queen takes A7 Queen takes A7 anyway you
have a queen B5 and queen B2
ah white still fighting for the draw it
should be a draw but
somewhat to be done the spawn is
attacked this Pawn is uh for a week long
term
but the big question is in the game what
happens if commit moves back right
because white seems to have a material
advantage but I'm not sure because there
is a huge attack possibility for black
with the pair of Bishops so let's say
queen D1 yeah maybe it's just Bishop I
just Bishop F4 so simple
mm-hmm anisha's been doing his puzzle
Rush tactics
so that's the hidden idea you just move
the bishop out of the way
I thought he wants to have some
compensation going back to B8 Bishop A6
the bishop is completely out Queen D6
bringing the Knight and stuff like that
but which before is simple yeah yeah
even this looks uh like great practical
compensation for black maybe not enough
though after white just blocks uh still
looks very scary I must admit for Abdul
satoroff but yeah Anish he's calculated
Bishop some neither five Knight H4 yeah
but Bishop F4 seems just a very simple
way of having an advantage a safe
Advantage the white Bishop has to move
you have to escape and actually you win
a pawn at the end here even if you
didn't win a pawn you have a big
Advantage due to the weakness of this
guy so actually maybe we have to go back
to Knight B5 maybe that's the
objectively the best way for a ride to
save the game
this is the only thing we've seen so far
Knight B5 nice spot Ivanka it wouldn't
be on my radar at least not
instinctively he might calculate his way
to this conclusion very ugly move maybe
it's the best but it's ugly thank you
yeah but going entering into the pin
right this is not your dream generally
speaking it's a desperation right that's
that's very true there is actually one
other move because I should say four
anyway I did check with the computer
Queen goes to C4 is the other
alternative
wow so in this position Queen to C4 no
instead of Knight B5 I noticed that a
knight B5
and yeah that is just saying after
Bishop F4 you just got Bishop A6 and
that's it big deal exactly
yeah but you rather play it with black
yes I think uh the momentum has
definitely shifted to a niche definitely
yeah I can see that on the body language
of do photography spending a long long
time now spending nearly 10 minutes on
this one move uh deep in thought Anish
away from the board
we talked about time trouble he's under
40 minutes and in the current position
it is only move 19 so they're not even
halfway to the time control this could
potentially end in a scramble especially
if Abdul store couldn't solve his issues
in the next few moves Queen C4 and
Knight B5 have to be found yeah and
talking about this unusual time control
once they're in that scramble
how easy is it to get out of it when you
only have a 10 second increment per move
after move 40. you don't get out exactly
right Eternal damnation
you just enter into the time trouble and
then you practically have no time to go
to the bathroom either right I mean it's
not very easy to build up that time on
the clock with 10 seconds yeah that's an
important Point Judith like I've had
that a few times for myself deep into
the end game and suddenly it's like oh
my god I've only got 30 seconds left for
the rest of the game and I really want
to run to the bathroom like I can't
focus like uh the players need to get
that out of their system but so many
kind of uh yeah kind of pitfalls before
that point 40 minutes pretty much for
the rest of the game now for Abdul Torah
and Counting I learned a little hack
life hack life hack or chess hack when
you're in that situation maybe I
shouldn't like publicly say it but I'll
say it anyway between the three of us
and everyone watching
apparently what you can do is you can
call the Arbiter and go I feel unwell
[Laughter]
ever tried it no I don't have the guts
to do that kind of rule breaking but and
also I don't have the calmness or the
foresight to kind of like think I need
that and I'm just like literally I'm
panicking panic mode when it comes to
time travel yeah there's those kind of
life hacks in all sports I know I was
what I used to watch a lot of tennis and
sometimes the players they're like oh I
need an injury break just because
they're playing really badly and then
they get a little nice massage and then
5-10 minutes later they go in and play
again and normally they tend to be fine
but yeah this little kind of tricks of
the trade that you can use but you don't
want to be kind of relying on that oh
you don't have this timeouts in the game
yeah unless you're feeling unwell
keep that to yourselves
don't try it too often please don't try
it at home but uh yeah difficult moment
now almost 12 minutes in the tank for
Abdus tour of he's realizing now that he
has to backpedal it's definitely White
Plain for equality here no more chances
of the advantage and maybe that's not
what he was uh banking on when he
initiated this forcing variation yeah
probably when he played Knight D7 it
could easily be the case that he just
thought about the simplification which
we looked for the first line right
exchanging the Knight the bishop and
simplifying the Deep Pawn E Pawn
Exchange and then it's a very unpleasant
situation that you have to face with
something that oh I thought I'm just
simplifying and it's going to be a draw
let's go to the Armageddon and then
suddenly you realize that well if I go
Queen C4 if I go this or that and he
plays Queen C4
it's not really bad for white but it's
kind of he's the one who has to pay
attention to make sure that he's not
ending up having really isolated the
pawn with a passive play
yep and uh Anish you can tell he's
calculated this in advance he predicted
Queen C4 a little bit of hesitation but
uh just very wisely very professionally
checking his variations and he'll play
Bishop back to F4
within a few seconds uh it looks like
okay taking his hand back away
good good thing bye you know because
we've seen so many opportunities that
have been missed because we've
instinctively reached out for the move
the worst is when you actually have your
hand on the piece and your brain goes
hang on a second
you could have played this and you would
have won on the spot and you just
literally go to your brain but why did
you not suggest that
10 seconds later earlier you know why
wait until I've actually committed to
moving that piece happened to me a few
times I was very frustrating
sometimes the eyes move faster than the
brain can kind of Click into gear yeah
so definitely uh it's worth a moment or
two to pause especially if like an issue
have a lot of time on your clock and
Bishop f4 on the board and that whole
variation we showed Judith where white
is suffering slightly but should it be
fine ultimately
um yeah really nice way that anisha's
played this game so far and how about
this Clash we talked about Hikaru and
Wesley how about this one if it went
down to Armageddon favorite
I'm sorry I have a very quick question
can't white go away with the rook and
after Queen C8 to play D5
wow okay let's jump back into an
analysis board
I just uh want to see what's there like
Rook C2 let's say okay
and I wanted to see a D5
okay so hitting this one and some uh
attacks here also yeah two Bishops under
a fire
what is Black's best move
hmm
I didn't see a way to deal with this
Bishop is trapped on C8 and you do have
some moves
Bishop traps ah okay you're actually in
this position too yeah no no not in not
on the D5 just one move earlier because
I feel that's the time where we have to
run through everything maybe yeah I was
thinking B5 yeah
just to try and deflect away the White
Queen from uh also Queen C7 was a tricky
move yeah 67 as well C7 I know between
C7 uh Queen C7 Bishop A6 defending the
queen right uh you wanted for example if
White's yeah it's the same place oh I
don't know please repeat one some
strange movie you want to take this
board yeah
and then yeah I had in mind
yeah so maybe B5 here and the idea is
after Knight takes Pawn
okay still a bit tricky but at the very
minimum we can take this and take now on
C8
maybe there's something even better than
this for black but here again two
Bishops Against The Rook big advantage
okay but okay
yep
nice uh Dodge there of any tactics any
tricks by Abdus turov now once Anish uh
kind of double checks himself he's going
to take this rook and it will be a small
Advantage for black but nothing too
major
yeah Armageddon who would you pick Abdi
satoroph or giri Gary really
yeah yeah so you fine um before this
game I would have been your back aside
now I'm not so sure giri is just so good
in the opening yeah he is so good he's
really good at the opening but you know
he will start with less time
yes he is fast but I've just I just
think that Abdul satoroph is so
resourceful and so quick and you know
when we judge the scores annoy Blitz we
still have produced a tour of six points
Anish finished in night eighth Ninth
Place no seventh eighth place sorry
yeah after tourists just on forming
speed chess but yeah it often gets down
to kind of some small details and if
Anisha survives the opening it's going
to be very hard for every sator of that
but uh let's kind of zoom out of this
one meanwhile there have been some big
developments in other games uh let's
check in maybe on uh Fabiano against
Magnus Carlson uh because Queens are off
uh on that board if I'm not mistaken and
some changes there also some tactics
happening on other boards we'll get
around to those but first Fabiana
caruana against Magnus Carlson and
things have changed dude
oh yeah seems like the
there is some over crowded Rooks on C7
C8 because Fabi wants to trap the C7 one
with Bishop F4 in the next move
yeah there's pieces of huddle too close
together you need some breathing space
he's definitely the black pieces are not
respecting the personal space of their
fellow pieces here
but how do you
just unhuddle those pieces I mean it's
very difficult Bishop F4 as you point
out serious threat on the board and also
this Knight on B6
it's such a horrible piece we're going
back again yeah again again I think
criticizing that night
didn't you learn your Basics about where
to put Knights never put a knight
opposite a pawn like this you just get
dominated nowhere to jump
sorry magic get this sorry I just uh
accidentally peeked at the computer
there's only one move to keep Magnus in
the game wow only one move yeah
everything else gives quite a decision
everything will give white like a plus
one advantage wow should we get student
sure uh I see this threat I want to play
Bishop D6 maybe but then we give up the
G5 Square F6 E6 well you guys Magnus has
found it oh wow
Bishop A3 I only move classy stuff and
the top players more often than not if
you give them a narrow path just one
move to survive they'll find it the
question is why is this the best move
that's the other question
Rook D1 Knight B4 or something uh maybe
looking for concert play wants to move
the Knight out the way to give the black
Rook on C7 some breathing space
how does white react first of all you
mentioned Rook D1 do we want Rook E1
which one
yeah rookie one or Rook D1 it's a big
question
E1 looks kind of uh more logical to be
on the E file
potentially setting up some tricks
against the black E6 Pawn Yeah
yeah should we jump in with some uh some
lights let's go rookie one okay let's
jump in and uh let's play it Rook E1 on
the board
and last night before right that's the
idea must be the idea let's just point
out that pawn takes Pawn will backfire
on black because this Rook is trapped
white wins material so in that before
we're assuming
yeah there was no change with Bishop A3
in this motive now the question is
whether Knight E5 for example that's
also possible or just simply let's start
with f takes E5
yeah F take C6 First Take yeah Knight G5
or Knight F4
so a queen's on the board you'd be
checkmating Black by this point with a
knight on G5 but where do I run
let's say I run somewhere G4 D7 or yeah
Bishop t7 Maybe
and now how do we keep the momentum
going Knight F4 Knight F4 of even
without Queen studio you want to well I
don't know but it's very tempting to go
with Knight f496 but now actually The
Rook on E1 has its plus that I can go
somewhere on the file at the same time
Bishop B4 is not possible and grabbing
the pawn on D5 because it's going to be
hanging right though it's a very nice
mate Checkmate if let's see if two item
move okay let's see if you just make a
move Rook B8 or something nonsense just
to show the fun Bishop B4 takes Knight
D5 Bishop b197 Knight F7
just for the fun of it
definition of smothered mate I thought
you were going to go with this one
Judith uh just on the theme of Checkmate
I think we're going to take here and
King in the corner and then oh wait
where's it then it's no no mate oh is
there I thought I was seeing something
flashy here maybe there's no chat mate
it's winning but uh no immediately
wow 95 95 engage eight Knight G6 is not
mating
four
but unfortunately black has the Saving
Grace Just G5 and Bishop D2
back and block any checks
Yep this uh won't happen if we're
questioning that at home but it's the
type of thing that are on the player's
minds and right now it looks promising
though for white somehow rookie one
It Feels Right instinctively of course
Fabio will back that up with deep
calculation though 30 minutes left for
him against almost 40 for Magnus
rookie one
yeah I don't think he needs to look too
far beyond that
feels like the most active Square for
the white Rook still some tactics coming
so why not put your Rook on an active
Square potentially
should we wait for Fabi to make a move
should we check in on some of the other
games I see tactics in the game with
farrugia against gokesh let's uh dive
into there because uh Fabi has a lot of
options here
yeah and uh Fabi will come back to that
game very shortly there's actually
tactics everywhere mamajarov against
Harry as well but let's go to uh farusha
against kokesh first
and Knight takes before an idea you
mentioned a bit earlier drew that is uh
it has appeared on the board and there
have been some big moves big decisions
we'll check back in on this position in
a moment let's just see how we got here
uh we last joined it in this position
and actually our prediction game was on
point after F take C6 Knight Queen G4
did happen you've had kids move Knight
E5 the queen dropped back and now
utilizing the fact that this bishop is
only defended once by the White Queen
black has grabbed a pawn
well there are some action gonna happen
maybe bishop H6 now
yeah that's Bishop's dying anyway might
as well throw it out the way
but Bishop A6 well I know it's too late
should have been better it would have
been better much earlier but let's say
Bishop 86 Knight D3 let's jump in with
some uh variations here Bishop takes H6
Knight bd3 everything's hanging this
Rook this Pawn this bishop
yeah we should point out as well every
time white wants to play Knight E4 it
will backfire due to the move Knight F3
check uh you've kind of cleared this uh
diagonal clearance sacrifice if the pawn
captures the Knight then this will end
in Checkmate nowhere to go so this is
going to be very relevant for the next
few moves absolutely
yeah so maybe bishop takes H6 this line
we showed that Judith looking good for
black
or at least visually uh looks very
appealing just everything hanging in the
white Camp so can we put a spin on this
can we
do it differently somehow yeah well I I
don't see a way to do that one
differently
but I see a lot of options like so
I guess you could also no you can't your
tactic that literally you spelled it out
for us because I was like maybe you can
go 94 but literally the one tactic that
you showed I've fallen for it again
yeah 94 black will throw the Knight out
of the way with Queen Knight F3 check
and the queen infiltrates yes so you
can't do that and is this safety first
if we just take this Knight Queen takes
and then just take this Pawn I was
thinking about that too and tried to
kind of play opposite color Bishops but
it does feel that black has a lot of
play on the dark squares well and the A3
Pawn is going to be a strong one not a
weak one yeah finally and also yeah
Bishop B6 going back to the diagonal so
very dangerous for white yeah I think
this is not an option what the fear Jose
is calculating
but what else simply the bar is roughly
in the center and
black has grabbed a pawn so there must
be a solution for whites
I sense uh time scramble incoming under
half an hour now for farrugia you need
something now what is it
well maybe what do you think about
playing Rook D1 I don't know which Rook
but one of the Rooks let's say
let's say the A1 That's The Logical one
and after Knight D3 Bishop E3
creating a pin here
how does black unravel can you try to
cement that night
with C5
yeah
B5 defense
C4 I'm coming should I spawns Ivanka
I do like that comment from tour that
says that Tony that says uh Pawn has
been on A3 since the Middle Ages
what about F4 yeah oh wow in the there
at the end oh at the end of the
operation yeah okay so Rook D1 Knight
into D3 and here F4 is not good enough
that black can just push Pawn so white
wants to get some of the action too
and wow crazy stuff but I'm defending
this night sufficiently for now I guess
can I just move
you just move away
to move but but uh just looking at the
tactics maybe you can go C4 yeah maybe
that's the one we're just going I've
I've tell you one thing that I have
learned so much Bishop G5 whoa whoa on
the board Bishop here we were looking
every Square other than this bishop G5
move
double exclamation mark from
alarismo what an amazing move
wow yes it's strange because you would
always just think Bishop takes Pawn
capture and here this is the best move
attack The Rook wow absolutely
incredible move
yeah and uh let's try to get to the root
of this the bishop can be captured
simply uh and there we see it is a
brilliant move an unexpected and amazing
move of course putting the bishop on a
square it could be taken for free but
the Black Knight will then fall and
after 0.6 Bishop Pawn takes Knight this
black pawn structure is really shaky
later you can't do it yet but later you
can hope to get your knight in to take
the spawn of Black's King
very weak beautiful stuff and also if
the black king ever has to run into the
corner it's no longer going to be safe
he's going to get hit by the White Queen
what a beautiful move Bishop D5 Bishop
five that's a mark of Genius we know
these players are good but that's
another level I think it would have
taken me an hour and and I would need to
be told that there was a good move in
order to find that one but also at the
same time we can say that it was a very
difficult moment so by elimination you
can also get there
possibly
yeah I agree with the comment there in
the featured chat and Larissa is a beast
yeah and uh okay let's uh go back to the
bird's eye view because I can actually
see that one of the games has finished
in a draw between chakra mamajov and
Arian tari so we will be seeing our
first Armageddon
and let's uh let the tension build a
little bit longer and we're going to
take a quick break and we will see you
shortly
did you teach uh certain positions or
openings or middle games or what what is
that your TR what did your training uh
people look like I'll give you one of
the secrets here so a good a good coach
will correct your moves but a great
coach will correct your thinking
and um all right hold on hold on I want
to repeat that again for the people in
the back can you just repeat that again
so a good coach will correct your moves
and a great coach will correct your
thinking so really part of the magic of
coaching is holding a mirror up to a
child's so they can see their own
thinking
and sometimes you made the move because
you were overconfidence uh you were
dismissive of your opponent and so these
whether they were this kind of
self-knowledge the self-awareness is
part of the cognitive process and it
helps to accelerate their learning curve
as as players
um and so meaning games in that loss
because you didn't know the Roy Lopez
even though the 14th move of the Roy
Lopez or because you couldn't execute a
rook and partner and game yes of course
these are these are technical things
that you need to win chess games but
games are also lost because of lack of
self-knowledge so
um
the issue of spasticity losing super
Trojan uh you know and I tell the story
many times butaski lost the world
championships have chosen in
1966. spasticity goes back to bafanink
and he says you know why did why did I
lose now uh people many people may not
know but spasky was an incredibly
talented chess player right in many ways
he's considered one of the first
Universal chess player he can attack
like a towel and he can defend like
petrosion but he loses this match and
Buffet told him uh the great talented
Boris basket uh did you study but Trojan
right so meaning it wasn't he didn't
think it was important to study the
opponent the famous line from Sun Tzu
know your enemy know yourself in the
Thousand battles you you will never lose
uh heathus thought it was about about
Sebastian and so he had to take the time
and recognize that he needed to
understand petrosion beating you means I
must understand you chess is a
conversation is a dialogue between the
two chess players so by 1969 he knew
what to expect at the chessboard he has
he has studied uh the Trojan and he
eventually becomes uh the 10th uh world
champion
[Music]
foreign
welcome back and there you can see the
playing Hall of the Norway chess where
the players are fit and fighting and two
people who will be in fighting mood will
be Shakur out Mama jarv and Ari antari
because they have drawn their first game
and that means only one thing their
match will be decided by our magadon our
crowd favorite and David talk us through
how that result happened yeah so we did
earlier check in on this game between
mamajarov and ariantari and actually we
slightly preferred Black's position but
it did boil down to a draw eventually
and this was the moment where the
simplifications started it looks like
black has a dominating position with
this beautiful night on the D3 Square
White's passport nicely blockaded as
well if black gets a move or two more to
push further forward black would have a
huge Advantage but managerov did pull
the break at the right time he found the
nice move B3
just keeping an eye on the black pawn
structure there Black's night
unfortunately needs to be kept an eye on
Black's pawns are tied down and after
Ariana decided to offer the queen trade
Knight takes B5 a really flashy tactic
here to force the draw Knight takes B5
double exclamation mark As we see there
unexpected the sacrifice but also
brilliant and the idea here is Queen
takes Knight would be met by pontex pawn
and actually it's white who wins because
next move the Black Knight would fall
instead Ariane had to bail out with Pawn
6 B3 also a double exclamation mark move
equally brilliant foregoing the Black
Knight and we saw the game end
peacefully after Rook takes night the
queen taking the White Knight and
everything getting traded off the board
at this level rook and 3 versus rook and
three is a simple draw and the players
did agree to one there straight to
Armageddon chess
yeah it was a fun game in the beginning
you could see that actually my major did
not get really an advantage at all
in the beginning of the game black Atari
played very well very actively
defended his spawns on C4 and then here
he went on exchanging the center so it
was a very balanced game good play good
Harry yes but the play must continue
because they will be playing the
Armageddon and we you mentioned that
Shaq didn't get too much of an opening
advantage
do you think he will switch it up
this is a very big question because I've
seen previous events that many of the
players they follow up with the same
preparation they go on with the same
line right but I'm not sure I think
shark can easily switch depending on his
mood whether maybe he was not so happy
with the opening and and let's face it
he has to win it's a master win
situation for him and he knows it that
he's very fast he has more time so
definitely he wants to pose problems to
tari and I think there is a good chance
that he will switch Yeah and well we'll
find out because the game will be
kicking off in roughly 15 minutes a time
and of course we will be there following
all the action
I can't wait for Armageddon it's my
personal favorite
[Laughter]
well the players have to really switch
completely in a different mode in their
mind while they had the time calculating
making strategies deciding making
decisions after so many minutes that
they were spending during the game now
they have to switch completely and
intuition comes into place
yeah and uh just while we wait for that
Armageddon action to begin let's jump
back into some of the games that are
ongoing uh we left this game between
Notre back Abdul satorov and Anish giri
just a few moves ago but suddenly things
have changed Queens are off the board
white is left with a really desperate
defense here uh he does have a huge
weakness on the D4 square and my only
question here is how big is Black's
Advantage do we think he can convert
this one to anishikiri
well first of all one thing is sure that
he's extremely happy because this is
more than a dream out of these kind of
positions right this is absolutely a
dream attacking the D4 pawn and then you
don't know whether you really want to
take it or just attack it for 30 moves
and only after then to take it
so I think Abdul saturov is in huge
danger right now
I mean can he take the path of most
resistance and Go Active with his Rook
I mean obviously that's going to be the
plan uh with white yeah with white but
uh like to move but it's black to move
yeah I know Knight takes D4 right now is
not clear because Rook D1 is not
possible to night check right to it so
an after Knight D4 black white has to
take on D4 Rook D4 white gives it check
on C8 first in order to push away the
king to H7 so the F7 Pawn is not
protected anymore and then Rook C7 with
the double attack
and and now of course it can continue
playing King G6 for example with the
same idea and pattern going to happen
after Rook A7 to give it check on the
event first pushing the king to H2 and
after Rook D2 both phones are under
attack
but white can play B4 right and after
Rook F2 Rook B7
Rook A2 and then this is how we are
exchanging pawns but still always black
has one Pawn extra Pawn Yeah and long
term unless there's something immediate
these uh postpones will decide the game
so this looks extremely tempting here
Judith maybe whiten for example just
saved this one I'm not sure exactly how
I want to do this for example let's step
back it's a passive square and suddenly
if I can exchange off these two pawns
the A and B pawns the four versus three
on the king side alone that should be
holdable yes but I think in this
position there is a very good chance
that black would be starting it with H5
or playing somehow if let's say black
pawn would be on H4 right that would be
a completely different story so now
white should be playing H4 I think is
the best move because if A5 I think
black takes and H4 and that's a very
difficult end game to hold unless you
have a concrete draw with Rook A4 and
Rook A7 going back and forth but if
let's say black would be able to play
King F6 and G5 that would be something
that it's it's very difficult to to hold
for a wide because it's a very important
strategic way of playing Black having on
on H4 and actually we are going to reach
this position it seems because there is
an exchange of knights and the check on
C8 is
given endocrine C7 yeah I'm surprised
I've got saved by anisha's decision it
makes a lot of sense especially if he
can reach an endgame like that one Jude
it but uh I don't know I would have been
so tempted to just put delayed attention
from for example a move like G5 is this
really going away anytime soon this Pawn
I don't know I mean I'm I'm a bit of a
lazy calculator so unless I saw a direct
win I would have been reluctant to go
into that Rook component game which does
have drawish Tendencies maybe check one
see and then
counter play yeah that's that's what I
wanted to do when I thought it was wides
to play
yeah maybe this is uh yeah Knight D4 you
go Knight Arrow K7 uh-huh
just uh to avoid the same Rook end game
but with me having improved my Pawn
structure yeah this one does look like
it should fizzle out towards a drawer so
okay Anish just decided to cash in now
and he will enter a rook and game oppon
up this is the current position
and we're expecting uh here black to
Simply defend his F Pawn and yeah go for
white spawns immediately afterwards the
exact variation you showed Judith I
don't know if it's possible for black
for example to play F6 maybe it's a
better version and after rookie seven to
go Rook D1 and row D2
yep let's jump rf5 both are option but I
think we'll get to know this later
whether where the opponent stands better
or safer
so let's say F6 Rook A7 check
King moves King moves Rook D2
uh is there a difference in this
variation now because maybe I can play
B4 like you highlighted and this Pawn is
weak at the end
yeah yeah you see you see this is why I
cannot go F6 yeah and here black would
be winning Pawn up but one move too slow
I can take your Pawn okay so this is why
F6 is not possible
so if we go back to the game position
likely to see King G6 I think so
yeah just a Defender this one I think
this one's more important than the
others
you don't really want to save your a
pawn for example here you could maybe
hunt down this B2 Pawn but uh the end
game like this one
I mean this E Pawn is just going to be
two yeah the E6 bone is just falling off
yeah
so King G6 from Anish we're expecting
and can he grind out Victory from this
end game that's the key question Abdus
should have enough time to hold you
would think
uh time travel won't really play an
issue in this game
and okay King G6 is on the board so
Anish Gary in the driver's seat this end
game is going to go on for a long time
though I think we can guarantee that one
should we check in on some of the other
action sure against that one is so
complicated I think that's the most
likely candidate for a decisive result
in the classical portion at least so far
and we do see
okay the players playing extremely
quickly in uh the other game but this
one
tense we saw a brilliant Bishop G5 move
from Abdul sotorov oh sorry from alareza
and uh let me make sure I get the right
game here uh it is this position
and wow this one the black king is not
safe at aldrude
well uh yeah
White made this bishop g5s in order to
make it unsafe and Pawn on G6
interestingly standing covering the H5
square and actually gives a good shelter
later for the king I think on G7 and the
E5 Knight is exceptionally well placed
as a Defender and as a great active
piece as well octo Knight Ivanka with
all of its eight tentacles out yeah it's
a very impressive night I have to say
I'm not also
quite impressed how Black's King looks
remarkably safe
despite having a lot of air around it
yeah maybe I was here if white can't
generate an attack remember he is a pawn
down and we laughed at this guy the A3
Pawn could this decide the game long
term
porn up yeah you said it
I didn't believe you
that's something if you forget to take
the opponent's pawns they might later
become Queens sir
and just and also just to mention the
clock times you know alireza just under
20 minutes and well he has 12 moves to
play before he can start getting that 10
second increment but there will be no
like added time to give him any form of
relief any time to catch his breath he
just has to be in Hustle mode which we
actually have seen early Reza from
yesterday's Blitz event
be absolutely absolutely Supreme there
and you know it's so interesting to see
gokesh who is just uh turned 17
yesterday right that when you you see
this talented very young players
they have respect for the older players
well we can say alireza as an older
player just few years but he has a huge
experience in this level already right
for the last two three years or maybe
already four
and I remember when giri was for example
like 15 or so and I was playing with him
in one tournament and you can say on him
they have this extremely great
self-confidence they I mean you're on
the edge whether they really respect you
or not really I mean they just criticize
you asking questions and and this is why
it's uh it's many of the games becoming
really interesting that you fill this uh
thing that I'm not playing for a draw
I'm playing for a win I want to ask
questions I'm going to make these
challenging moves I'm calculating myself
and then you see this this game
happening right here and and look at who
catch the way he sits there he has this
self-confidence his
happy with his position he's focused
right and he's playing with world number
two yeah
I mean that's how he burst to what was
it seven out of seven or eight out of
eight at the Olympiad uh on board one
for the India youth team the India's
second team uh just no fear at all no
respect just I mean he took down Fabiano
uh with the black Pieces Just by going
at it and it was just as crazy as this
uh type of position I mean they have
respect for the players but they they
they they they don't have this crazy
respect that it would block them to give
out their strengths right they're not
deferential at all you know they're just
like well you know you've given me a
pawn I think a pawn is worth a little
bit of trouble
and uh very impressive start from gukesh
um also now alireza in a difficult
situation because he does have to
generate something and it's
it's very difficult to see a clear-cut
path towards the black king you know
what is very annoying in this position
for white look at that Bishop on E6
and it's like it got lost
no lost in the forest alone trapped
Behind Enemy Lines it's like it seems
like it's close to the king and it's
active and so on and it has also a good
Outpost if it goes back to B3 but
actually it's like eating up air on that
diagonal it doesn't give any disturbance
for black
no it's it certainly it doesn't give any
disturbance but uh I think that this
will be something that alireza does have
to focus on and he'll be using some time
on his clock to deal with because well
we do have an Armageddon about to start
any second now and there we can see our
antari playing with the black pieces
getting ready to meet Shakura mamajarov
and
well Ariane will start with seven
minutes on the clock number jar of 10
minutes who is our favorite
on paper you would have to say manager
of high rated player he's got the white
pieces he was exceptional yesterday in
the blitz tournament at least for the
majority of that event uh Aryan
struggled yesterday in the blitz but did
take down Magnus uh that being said he
looked like he played a great game there
tarry uh never in trouble at all with
black remove one and he's also an ex
extremely well prepared player so this
one I do think it's in the ballots
uh-huh I'm not gonna say manager is a
big favorite there is track record last
year they did play um with exactly the
same colors and it was a very similar
story actually REM played very well with
the black pieces easily neutralized
Harry I'm sorry easy neutralized mama
jarov and then when it came to the
Armageddon you know married Shakura just
like switched it up here and there and
got a very comfortable position and then
in the chaos just won it
well I'm pretty sure now also mama jarov
is trying to shuffle things and make
some chaos because he has all the
self-confidence he has lots of
experience in that and he he's really
feeling in the the best shape when he he
can get those kind of positions and
and get
shape
and now also yesterday the best
tournament he beat Magnus and he has a
few interesting games and I think it's
very important for him to be able to
hold this again
and when I mean draw or when is victory
in points right yeah and we're off it's
Armageddon chess the players have
switched things up uh we have
accelerated the speed of play of course
it's gonna be fast and you can tell by
the speed of play that every second
counts in this Armageddon format let's
see what's going on in that battle how's
the opening uh preceded things have been
changed by Mama jorov he's the one
switching to a new opening here and okay
it's this kind of hybrid
I was just gonna ask the question will
he play G4 and look at that game review
says bad move how dare you play such a
coffee house question doesn't understand
the psychology of the moment right this
is the problem of that otherwise the
genius move I mean this is the way Mama
is doing it right before in any position
Queen's Pawn opening English opening
ready just G4 and uh so there is a good
question what if just black the X and G4
and after G1 Bishop F6
I think we're going to find out the
answer to that question Knight takes G4
tari taking debate he's calling the
bluff and yeah it's up to manager of to
work his magic now of course white does
line up The Rook with Black's King I
think you might be right Bishop F6 just
neutralize White's fianca to Bishop on
B2 must be the way it has to be the way
and uh I can see there from the comments
on chat that everyone loves Shaq's
decision live look at that they are in
the mood
I like F5 actually it makes a lot of
sense as well same idea as your student
I think he'll play Bishop's next move
but first uh just gaining a bit of space
and actually it helps Black's defense
potentially to have access to more
squares
okay just developing as if nothing
happened of course but he has a threat
now to take on the E5 twice and then
Bishop C4 winning a queen
time to actually solidify that pawn with
C6 or
no oh he doesn't play that
but okay it should not take six Knight
takes D5 is not possible because the
Bishops are eyeing each other
yep he's
he's pinning along this diagonal I'm
expecting Shack now to just move his
Queen there we go Queen to C2 on the
board he's getting ready to Castle Queen
side potentially and tarry just
solidifies his center it's like the
Stonewall Dutch Now That Rock Solid Pawn
formation the question is can white
break through that poor information can
he break through Black's defenses
I'm so skeptical but now the evaluation
part doesn't hate White's position I
think a great psychological idea and the
time advantage of three minutes
still maintained Harry's got a lot of
questions to answer with only 5 minutes
40 on the clock well I have the feeling
that the it's going to be kind of a
position upon sacrifice after Knight E2
let's say somehow exchanging the black
Square Bishop pushing H3 and then having
Knight on E5 eventually
with having these bones on D5 F5 there
is a little uh danger for black that the
E5 Square will be occupied with one of
the Knight and the other Knight will be
even helping it out
a long thing though do you have ideas
like H3 as well
because the Knight is forced to go back
to H6
maybe on the next turn maybe that's why
he's uh pushed D4 now he's locked the
center which kind of comes with pros and
cons it's going to be harder for whites
Queen side pieces to shift to attacking
the black king but he's gripped onto
squares that Judas mentioned an A5 from
tarry it's as if he's just playing a
normal kind of Dutch defense just with
an extra Pawn as black
yeah makes a lot of sense and he's also
getting ready preemptively to attack the
white king if it does Castle on the
queen side we see by Chuck's hand
movements there long Castle is there on
the board I mean it had to be played
right I mean Shaq is basically playing
with a one-track mind
castle of Queen side activate his pieces
pressure along the G line and of course
he wants to put a knight into E5
and style wise he's playing up his alley
here Shakira mamajarov but and Julia you
love to attack with white as well do you
think you see enough potential here for
white well I think there are some
opportunities for white playing Bishop
D3 at some point to play Rook G4
sacrificing some material of course C
takes D5 takes Knight D5 I would be
watching out but for the moment I think
it does not work
[Music]
um H3 is not uh something that white
would be rushing but he's doing it now
H4 Knight G5 that's a that's a great
Outpost for tonight and I'm expecting
Knight E2 Knight F4 also
um making his pieces work I mean it's a
thing of uh Beauty what he's doing
and Knight F7 on the board don't you
think it has a little style of uh Alpha
zero yeah I nearly said that actually
like three or four moves ago
yeah her piece is on the right
cloning species
design of uh getting lost and then in 20
moves things are on the right track yeah
it really reminds me of one game
specific game between Alpha zero and
stockfish where Alf uh stockfish grabbed
four pawns but gave up the dot Square
Bishop for example taking on H4 now
would backfire long term on the dark
squares nothing immediate just
domination long time
yeah yeah because for example in this
position we can ask that what is Black's
plan right
so maybe Knight d694 is something to to
play
or maybe also detect C4 and B5 at some
point or A4 B5 so the 90s on F4
yeah big threat on the board of uh
Knight takes Pawn also okay so Arya
flicking in a porn trade we need so
queenie7 yep
oh rookie eight feels a bit shaky for
black the Knight can come to H5 if
you're desperate to kind of chop this
bishop off later on and despite the fact
that the a file is open white uh the
black queen can give one check but the
white king will always be safe enough
it's very hard to deliver Checkmate if
the opponent has a feeling coated Bishop
like white does on B2 he's going for
Knight H5
and uh yeah this one's still in the
balance Anything could happen but
clockwise Tarry
four and a half minutes it's gonna be
hard to defend you've got to say it
could be decisive uh this time
disadvantage for him no easy moves well
and the bishop is getting off the board
the F6 will be captured
he's just gonna move faster just Queen
E7 just kind of sit and open can he try
for B6 you know just go Bishop B7 you
know at least that get that piece
somewhat into the game yeah you're right
Ivanka this is a dead piece right now I
would even think of B5
I thought about B5 as well but at the
same time you know I like to give up the
point exactly
while long think now for an Armageddon
game almost one minute on the clock uh
on this one move actually for from
ariantari Down Under four minutes this
is uncomfortable on the camera this is
exactly what uh Mama Jara was looking
for right to have a complicated game
putting pressure on uh tari posing
problems making Atari to make decisions
and but making decisions it means that
you're expending your time all the time
yep and he is now under four minutes and
remember if the players do have to reach
move 41 before they get that one second
increment which really is not a lot of
time in an end game it helps one second
to increment but in a crazy position
like this one it definitely doesn't help
at all and okay Queen to A5 hinting at a
counter attack but no real threats for
black yet
how shot gonna improve his position I
would be inclined to just kind of
develop and hope that the tension uh
favors white a bit later on well my G5
is a very tempting move isn't it oh
Route One straight for the black king
that's more his style we're gonna see it
on the board it is on the board unit
you're channeling your inner Shack
or perhaps the other way around yeah
Jack's uh channeling his inner Junior
poor guy here
wow yeah I I think if you had this
position against me or if you had whites
I would just resign just I know I'm
getting checkmated
yeah but I mean how is white gonna break
through because I'm assuming that black
does move the Knight I mean you can't
open up the H line at all
put the Knight on edge
for the moment what would you play with
black knight D6 no 96 you get kicked
away with uh C5
and somehow other I see a check and that
scares me so
and if but then it's not sweet it's not
so easy
move yeah you might need to he just
needs to move faster RN he spent another
one minute on this movement Knights on
the edge of the board again
it's not a healthy looking move he's
lost a bit of time there he's lost two
Tempe moving his Knight back a couple of
moves ago and now again to the edge of
the board surely that gives the shack
time to attack it certainly does but I
mean as long as he starts surviving and
he obviously he has to do it as quickly
as he can and one thing that I would
suggest is like B6 I really do like B6
at one time and yeah I was trying to get
some like horizontal defense with the
Rook on A7
yes probably that's a good idea a nice
defense
and B5 played I'm not sure Queen G2
right now is not uh
the Killer
might well be
or some tactics I see there seven Knight
of six yeah I think if he plays it now
arian's gonna struggle to defend with
only two and a half minutes on his clock
first he locks down the queen side makes
a lot of sense keeping the white king
safe for the rest of the game Aaron's
playing very slowly though B4 oh I think
you needed to go over K7
yeah and uh now Judith's move Queen G2
might
be uh yeah might end the game tactically
if black isn't careful there's going to
be all sorts of checkmating ideas in
connection with Queen takes G7
I think I would just be too tempted I'd
have to play it
you would you could not resist to play
Queen G2 yeah but I mean can black just
grit their teeth and just put the Rook
on G8 and go holding
I could hope so but at least this Pawn
Falls as well that's true
yeah but now what about Queen A2 look at
that grenade too and if King C2 Knight
C5 whoa
Queen A2 oh wow we see a question mark
attached to it
but I I I'm sorry it's my move I think
it's a good practical try to I think
you're right but probably is just the
Checkmate somehow King C1 and uh wow he
steps up the board but
okay Knight takes C5 is coming black can
counter-attack now against six
oh yeah it's just one check yeah one
check is only a check
and it's what you talked about earlier
in the day of anchor winner black queen
is so far distance from her own King
there's no way ever to defend uh Black's
King is kind of left on its own
defenseless
under two minutes now for tarry three
and a half minutes for white for
managerov
how to defend this brutal attack just
want to throw the white Knights out the
way right I mean are you forced to go
Rook too oh no but you have Rook A1
happening as well
wow big threat of the black queen being
trapped simply maybe that's why he uh
this last move was deemed an error by
the computer Ariane jumping in a bit too
early a bit too soon with the black
queen
this one problem
oh he pushes his Rook forward okay
defending G7
makes a lot of sense
okay so the first question is can you
can you just Bank it and go okay one win
the queen
well
if you can't appreciate the extra Queen
style though Shaq is not greedy he wants
to be the one sacrificing I fully
understand that you just want to go
Knight H7 right yeah overnight E6 or
Knight H7 just get the Knight out the
way then eliminate the bishop then crash
through the White Queen
put no need for such beautiful chess
when caveman chess Works a rook A1 he
has gone for it a professional yeah
um
now it's just a case of being clinical
and Aryan now just over one minute and
it's moved 26.
who's here as black
Knight C6 looks like a killer that night
cannot be touched by the black Rook
because white will break through on the
G7 Square after eliminating the other
Bishop those two white Knights just too
strong the Destroyers of the position
and uh Ariana unfortunately he can't get
his Rook across to A7 to launch any
counter play because his own Knight is
in the way yeah it would be a great idea
yeah yeah
but those Knights on G5 and H5 and they
are killers
okay some hesitation though from
Muhammad yarov he needs to move he's uh
down to around two minutes this could
become a mad scramble
I agree this looks like a winning tactic
dude what else could he be looking at
maybe he's looking at a sacrifice on
this Square to bring the White Queen up
the board to G6 I was also looking at
the clinical ways again you know of
going Queen D2 and grab the B4 Pawn but
you know why not just end enjoy your
food
and he just goes the simple way after
Rook A7 Bishop B1
God the king very prophylactic though
very nice defense there from Mama jarov
and it's going to be hard for Tara to
even find a move now
yeah the White Knight will go back
transfer transfer it to Knight H3 Knight
F4
he tries to block that idea tarry really
nice defense there uh White can take
this Pawn but at the cost of his
structure I really want to get the queen
in on this Diagon as well before is also
something to consider
yeah
E4 bypass that pawn keeps the Black
Knights out of the game that's a very
amateur off type of move
he's really slowed down though one and a
half minutes against just under one
minute
the one second increment will be
essential for both of these players very
shortly and uh now Queen D2 on the board
yeah that one's a nice one you mentioned
it earlier Ivanka
going after the B4 Pawn
destabilizing the black Rook
not much to be done here
we do have updates in the other games in
the classical games I think we'll see a
draw any second now between Wesley so
and hikar and Nakamura but we will bring
a recap after this Armageddon game is
done uh Aryan jumps in with the Knights
F5
but it looks like that's not going to
save the day White's Queen can just
gobble up everything now
and it has and also the queen will find
a way to get to B8 and now will he trade
will he step forward with his e-pawn I
mean white has so many beautiful choices
and mama jarov has the time just to put
this game away
yep he has the time but we're not quite
at move 40 and uh okay look how fast the
players are playing now Rooks are off
the board just good professional cynical
chest trading things off when in doubt
when your material up that's always a
good strategy
well I think we're in the final moves of
this game
Harry simply has no time to physically
make the rest of the moves he needs to
get to move 40 in 20 seconds
but I think there was a maybe an easier
way for shark to finish the game because
now there are some chances well the
bishop will fall off the board or I'm
over optimistic
I think black
everything's falling
that's the problem
before
E4 he's breaking through he's going to
get to that black king on the light
Squad Square diagonal
and tarry down at seven seconds he's
still got three or four moves to make
can he do it physically
winning all the pawns but the black
kings getting active
well he's making it to move 40th this is
impressive uh piece play by Ariane you
can tell he's faster physically as well
too many pawns for white one extra Queen
on the board and another one on the way
oh and Aaron made that blue last move
was one second on his clock p7
there we go
with the black record captured that pawn
it would have fallen off the board after
a queen check
well this is unsavable
and there we have the handshake it is
who wins the Armageddon so he will walk
away with one and a half points whereas
orientari one point
um what a great game by Mama Joe I think
it was a perfect Armageddon game it was
a Fighting Chess aggressive and he put
pressure on Aryan from the get-go
basically he could convert his uh his uh
strategy what he had he could implement
it very well in a game right it move it
or it was move six G4 just give away a
pawn a mess yeah make a mess with the
pieces of of tari right it has to make a
decision wasting time long Castle
jumping with the Knight g592 Knight F4
Knight H5 and then let it go yeah and
someone who should be taking notes on
the mamajara strategy is Wesley so
because he will have the white pieces
against Hikaru in our next Armageddon
game which will be coming up roughly in
15 to 20 minutes
yeah I'm looking forward to that one two
great speed players facing off in
Armageddon and meanwhile we see a game
in front of us on the camera there we
see farrugia against gokesh we joined it
earlier just before we jumped into that
Armageddon game and we thought faruga in
big trouble and he's not just in big
trouble on the board on the clock he's
got 20 seconds left and he's not getting
out of time trouble there versus 25
minutes of gokish
it's it's not the good news and he has
10 moves to make in 20 seconds
to make every move on an average of two
seconds okay do you think he can do it
he's a good Blitz great blue bullet
player but over the board it takes time
he'll be knocking over pieces if kukesh
throws in a random move to surprise him
ID3 perfect to do one
and place it instantly
Knight F2
yeah and here we see Rook D1 branded
with a question mark not the best move
not the best uh defensive idea
what Knight C1 oh shoot it yeah game
over right jump to C1
hit the White Queen and the White Queen
is overloaded you will take this Rook he
will take this pawn and you'll win
yeah yeah
Knight C1 on the board if he finds it go
cash 24 minutes yeah should be plenty of
time
well this is exactly the moment right
when you have to win the game with black
otherwise you're going to curse yourself
for the rest of the tournament but you
have 25 minutes yourself versus 20
seconds and the better position they
were almost winning position and you
wouldn't find it so you have to make
sure that you do the right calculation
yeah and I've read I think it's kukash
who does some meditation sometimes and
some I think this is the perfect moment
23 minutes just kind of calm down your
breathing don't rush don't keep uh kind
of speeding along at your opponent's
Pace you have all the time in the world
he knows as well he's got a dominant
position so he will just kind of take a
step back zoom out as we were talking
about earlier and uh after a bit of
calculation he'll go for his move he
needs to forget about ferocious clock
he'll probably win on time anyway but he
wants to win on the board of course he's
a great professional cookish
20 seconds from Frugal though it showed
we discussed it earlier the players they
haven't necessarily adapted to classical
chess after the blitz action from
yesterday
certainly not and uh also good cash just
played a very good game you know he made
it very complicated he forced Ali Reza
to be on the back foot burn the time and
the result is this and I agree with you
guys I think gukash knows how to win
these type of positions he knows when
he's going to take a pause and this is
this the moment when you look at your
young opponent and you think my God
you're just 17 years old how is that
possible
yeah and this position looks winning for
black I just want to point out the black
A3 Point as well covers B2 no checks
beautiful strategy from kokesh
and uh okay wow action everywhere let's
go and check out another game this time
between uh Fabiano and Magnus and those
two heavyweights it looks like Magnus in
deep trouble in this game I think he
might have just has he blundered has he
missed something he's uh yeah lacking
squares for the Black Knight right now
there could be a devastating attack
against magnus's king and the clock
situation he's got time 14 minutes for
Magnus against eight but look at him on
the camera Magnus Carlson looking away
leaning back in his chair
the problem is how to defend this Black
Knight
well you can't because if you step back
with the Rook then a white simply goes
Rook takes Knight and there is a
terrible Fork on F6 so you can rule that
one out of the equation and that means
you have to move the Knight
yeah yeah you have to move the Knight
just to show that variation you
mentioned Ivanka and uh Rook E5 last
move on the board
I don't see what he can do if he moves
the knight in another direction for
example if he steps it back here to try
and trade then uh I think there will be
consequences in the other direction a
night check where's the king going
the name of this mate uh Ivanka you're
the expert here is this Arabian Arabian
Checkmate Rook takes H7 and the black
king is trapped Knight C3
Knight C3 I mean but a still it's the
same problem right I check the Knight
will come to F6 you have a check all the
bar drops though
hmm does Black's King have to just run
for the hills I think so run for the
Seas each foreign
uh maybe I have to go back in this
direction to hit your Rook at least
survive one move longer but just to show
that one Judith there's all sorts of
checkmates the black king facing White's
whole Army on its own
this is on the board
this position Magnus how is he going to
survive
I thought we'd see an armor get in here
but it's just been uh yeah beautiful
play by Fabiana karawana against the
French defense
Knight of six on the board
just goes to show you know you have to
maintain your concentration up
every stage of the game and one size
slip up and that's it
whoa that is a great start for Fabiana
Corona as he wins against Magnus Carlson
with white pieces and Nets three points
Magnus woes are just continuing
yesterday was a bad Blitz outing today
starting with a loss
yeah he's had a turret time so far
Magnus Carlsen just uh maybe showing a
bit of rust this was his first classical
tournament his first classical
Tournament game since January since uh
the Tata steel Masters and uh at this
top level
small margins decide things and Fabi
looking fresher there yeah and of course
uh Fabi actually coming off a great
Victory and the Bucharest super bet
where he won that classical event and
obviously he did very well at the chess
kid cup
by being grateful
yep Fabi in great form and uh let's go
back to that time scramble that we were
focusing on a bit earlier can farrugia
make move 40 gain that increment with
only a few seconds on his clock well he
had to give up his exchange after Knight
C1
and trying to hang on there
if I'm not mistaken here six seconds to
make seven moves
that's more than one move per second if
this was online if you could pre-move
that might uh be possible but here in
Mouse option would be helpful right ah
also a terrible position for weight
exchange down material down unless you
how bad is that I mean you can mix it
right so you can see situations where
black is a little bit careless with that
King
I mean is it Queen F4 that black has to
go back or is it true D2 the winning
move
still I think one or two precise move is
needed from Black
and one thing you must not do you must
not even dream about is going Bishop
takes Knight check if you do that or you
might be in huge trouble don't get rid
of that Bishop
and wow kakesh I would have played the
consolidating safety move he's gone in
with the black Rook
has he calculated that there are not
enough checks maybe the other black Rook
is coming uh to take on F2 and just
Checkmate that white king
some calculation to be done there
perhaps but it feels like uh there are
multiple ways to knock white out here
immediately and look at far Asia on the
camera he's not even looking at the
board he's got four seconds left
yeah
six moves to make in four seconds it's
just clock handling it decides games
increments is so important there are
Miracles you know
sometimes it's just
here it's hard to imagine dude yeah if
you if Ali Reza survives this he will
live to be a thousand
yeah well interesting thought
laughs
hell he wants to resign about him first
he looked he leaned back for a second it
looked like he was about to offer his
hand no way
okay takes the bishop wow he didn't even
use one second there for Asia yeah
probably takes on G2 takes takes Queen
D2 King
and the queen takes the E6 Bishop yeah
everything will be dropping
okay he didn't even try to be fast there
two seconds left for farusha four moves
to go
he's got to be ready he's going to lose
on time one second to make three moves
it's physically impossible his position
is lost as well
and he resigns
wow very good again I know what an
impressive play from the 17 year old
good cash defeating Ali Reza farusion
number two in the world with the black
pieces and
I'm I'm really astounded by this just
because uh gukash yesterday he struggled
in the opening Blitz and here finding
his poor form playing perfect chess
wonderful
well there was an opportunity for furus
yeah I'm very much wondering whether
firozan knows about it that he realized
it after he made Knight D4 or he's still
ahead of him to get this shock
that somebody will tell him yeah I don't
want to be the person who tells farooja
he missed a potentially winning move
earlier in the game but what a big day
Juliet Ivanka we've seen the world
number one and the world number two in
classical chess both lose in the
classical portion of no HS just huge
shocks and especially farooja losing
with white who would have expected that
one and uh yeah just the final position
there he resigned partly because of the
clock but also he had Rook Bishop Knight
one of them was destined to fall in the
next two moves the black queen was going
to uh win at least one piece and win the
game
I mean I remember when I was winning
some big victory I mean I was just ready
to jump up and enjoy the moment
the Silent Assassin yeah and uh one
classical game remaining and there we
can see it up on the screen it is
between naughty back Abdus Turf and
Anish giri are we gonna see a victory
for a niche or are we gonna go into
another Armageddon I think we're being
treated Ivanka it will be more chess
today it's going to be an Armageddon
Abdul satorov just took a second there
took a pause and uh wow he's stepping
forward with G6 I think there were other
safer ways to draw this game potentially
but
um but he wants to give a chance that he
might win
that's a race how's black stopping that
pawn do you have to run back with a
black king and keep it under watchful
gays wow
agreed the game was about to fizzle out
to a dead drawn Rook end game because
there was funny if you play F2 black and
loose you see
yeah if you play F2 then Rook f8
and F1 takes takes G7 and there is no
uh way of yeah stopping the phone oh
well let's show that on the board Judith
rook f8 and white would win you make a
new Queen Rook takes and whoa beautiful
this is it's important to notice that
this is very important skill I think for
players that you don't go for the fix
clear draw move but you make a move
where your opponent can still go and
make a mistake you know because that's
how Magnuson still wins his games and
many other players just because it's of
course you know it's a draw the opponent
knows it's a draw but still let's give a
chance for the opponent to make mistakes
right yeah even if it's a one percent
chance it's worth it why not they've
seen situations where the one percent
was in place
exactly and abdusatorov actually great
defense there we've got to commend him
he had a difficult Rook end game there
four versus three on the king side and
he managed to hold him the players
laughing about it that's nice to see but
they're going to be enemies again in 15
to 20 minutes Ivanka when they play on
again they will certainly be rivals on
the board but for now the players are
simply discussing the game and uh
sharing their thoughts and smiling it's
a beautiful moment
and well we we're going to be treated to
two Armageddon games and the first one
that will be coming up will be Wesley so
playing with the white pieces against
Hikaru Nakamura
yeah I've never seen abdusator of smile
in love so much I've got to say I know
anisha's a funny guy but I wonder what
variations they were discussing there
from their game well I think there is a
great Relief by abductor of it at this
point and there we can remind ourselves
of the Armageddon format the players
will be keeping the same colors that
they played in the classical portion
white will have 10 minutes black will
have seven minutes and one second added
will be well it will be added after move
40 and it's one and a half points for
the win and one point for the loss and
Hikaru he is seated and trying to get
into the flow and having said that he's
just left absolutely
[Laughter]
yeah
is it time to make oh he's back Ivanka
just On Cue yeah is it time to make
predictions out of these two Titans who
is going to prevail
in Armageddon chess is Nakamura going to
avoid defeat and take the point
[Music]
this format and he seems to have the
upper hand
against a lot of the American players so
I think Hikaru will manage to win this
in Armageddon
what about you Judith I go for wrestling
then okay
because I think even the Hikaru is not
very happy about the the last game I
think he thought it's going to be a
game there especially after the opening
or middle game he had it's very quiet
yes and uh while we wait for Wesley to
uh sit at the board and uh to choose his
opening to see whether he can win at all
costs in this Armageddon game I think we
might have a special treat but uh yeah
the action will begin any moment now
just in a few minutes time yeah and
and in the meantime let's have a look at
some of hikaru's big achievements he has
a very impressive resume I mean look at
this number five in the world ranking
five-time U.S chess champion he's also
American Cup champion he's reigning
five-time speed chess champion reigning
world Fisher random chess champion and
in 2023 with the protest League champion
with the Gotham Knight and on top of all
this he's like number one chess streamer
so a very formidable opponent there for
Wesley so
and
and the meantime while the players are
getting ready
we are going to be treated to a very
special guest in the studio
oh
yeah Fabiano
okay oh yeah we're very yeah very I
should mention who you are I shouldn't
just leave it as a mystery it is a
pleasure to have here in the studio at
Fabiana Carona who just beat Magnus
Carlsen with the white pieces
and how are you feeling Fabio oh it's
it's amazing um yeah it was a very tough
game and especially with the time
control it's so tough you know you get
back down to your last few minutes and
you're in a panic because you know that
you never get uh any more time and also
you have a 10 second increment so any
kind of complications and you'll very
unlikely to work through it but uh
everything I mean identity kind of
collapsed after I played this A3 I guess
he has some way probably to equalize and
he missed I guess rookie five he missed
a few things and
um but I was very happy with this Knight
D7 I had seen it when uh when I went for
this whole A3 thing and yeah after
rookie five it's just game over yeah and
uh took us through the beginning I mean
were you surprised by his opening Choice
the French defense I was surprised by it
but I wasn't surprised that I was
surprised I expected I expected a
surprise I just wasn't sure which one
and I had checked this line the last
time like seven years ago so I couldn't
remember anything I just remembered that
there is at some moment some Queen B5 is
supposed to be played I thought it was
maybe take on E5 and then Queen B5
instead of Queen A5 yeah but then I
probably misplayed it and in the end
game he plays night before I don't see
any advantage for me but this Rook C7
was very surprising to me I didn't um
didn't really understand the move it
just looks like The Rook is in a very
awkward place there and then I was
better but probably misplated it a bit
again
this Armageddon game is is quite quite
exciting would you like to share with us
your thoughts
I I don't think I've seen this Knight H6
like I mean F5 is a move right uh but
although I don't know if I've I I've
seen I mean this is a big position with
the Knight on B1 and pawn and H6 upon on
A7 survey six and then F5 is a move but
I haven't seen the conclusion of Knight
G4 and Knight H6 is is very unusual I
guess
uh Hikaru has has prepared some special
uh Blitz openings I mean Knight F1 is
critical now in that F5 and who knows
and uh what color would you prefer to be
playing in this Armageddon black white
like with my knowledge that I would take
white for sure
if if I was prepared for the position in
the way that I assume Hikaru is then
maybe I would take black okay and what
do you think of Wesley's reaction he you
know you mentioned Knight F1 he's gone
for occupying the center okay but now F5
it must be the move right F5 and the
Knight on B3 is away from the King side
uh it's not going to be able to defend
White's King potentially if there's some
counter play there
so I guess if five I mean otherwise
what's what's the point I mean he can
play Queen of Queen F6 Bishop G5 Queen
G6 but it looks a bit awkward there so
yeah suddenly and you're not afraid of
Bishop takes Knight
we can't I mean we put our Knight on H6
how can we be afraid of that that was
the whole idea if we're afraid of that
we should have kept it on F6
yeah
yeah F5 is the movie he's just screaming
right to be played yeah it feels it
feels like the moment right
a long think though from uh Hikaru right
now down to five minutes on the clock
and uh we've seen it today Fabby several
players can maybe struggling with the
time control for Russia leaving himself
20 seconds for over 10 moves uh do you
think that's gonna be kind of decisive
in the tournament standings after the
first few days
uh I think I think time trouble in
general will be a huge factor in this
tournament I think every round will have
a few time scrambles and a lot of games
decided by time management
um I mean especially in Armageddon
because Armageddon is basically all time
management isn't it
were you happy with the way you managed
your time today
uh not too much but it worked out so I
guess
um you know when things work out you
seem like a genius but uh if let's say I
got into time trouble and I had lost
control then I wouldn't have seemed
quite as smart let's say
Knight G8 What do you make of this
is that the knight in H6 you might as
well uh kind of live or die by it but
now it's sitting at home
yeah it's uh so he took
uh I mean I wouldn't
usually do this with black it felt like
F5 was the move okay he he's just going
to I think Hikaru has a very pragmatic
approach to these Armageddon games okay
he keeps the pace up he's he's not
trying to think too long he plays
healthy moves 97 is coming
um but Wesley certainly can be happy I
mean he can
yeah he can think I don't know if G
maybe G4 why not
it's G4 G5 can black do that well you
can lock down the game right and force
your opponent to play the longer game
seconds left on their clock I would yeah
if black could get G5 and ig6 and then
he should be pretty happy with that yeah
it was an interesting decision right not
playing F5 but going to Knight G8 and
then the slow side of the game yeah it's
not what I would have gone for but
it looks reasonable as well
and what's the ideal opening strategy
for white playing Armageddon because
obviously you're in a must-win situation
I mean do you play a tense position do
you kind of go for murky chess like we
saw Shakura did against orientare I I
think keeping up the tension that's the
main thing you don't want it to
um you have to think about what would be
difficult for your opponent to play
that's the main thing it's not really
about the objective evaluation but just
what's
what's easier for you to play uh and and
difficult for your opponent to play
and okay these days I play so much
Armageddon sometimes it works out
sometimes it doesn't I Like the Way
Wesley is doing this he's gonna play me
play G3 and uh Knight G6 G3 and Bishop
on G2 potentially
looks very very stable why it's a bit
better
and how do you consider do you prefer to
play with the white side does white have
have an advantage in Armageddon or is it
a secret I like to play with white I
usually
I usually go a bit high like when we're
doing this bidding on in the in the
chess.com tournaments I usually go a
little bit higher because I don't want
to be like some let's say car goes with
like seven minutes 30 seconds I I don't
I'm not gonna play with it eight minute
deficit and uh and no increment for the
rest of the game I I usually bid around
10 minutes and
if I get white then I'm I'm reasonably
happy uh and if I get black I'd prefer
to have a bit more time on the clock
because I'm not as uh not as good in the
time scrambles let's say as Hikaru or or
magnusar
and I mean how do you find playing with
no time over the board tournaments
because obviously the stress levels get
magnified like a thousand fold right
yeah it's it's it's pretty stressful I
have to say this tournament the time the
time control is stressful if uh if
you're looking for an easy life don't
play this one
what did Wesley do Bishop C4 F1 D3
it's very odd isn't it
uh black has an amazing position
yeah so
Bishop takes Knight H4 Queen F6 looks
pretty healthy right
yeah it certainly does look healthy
Knight H4 coming
oh
what do we think
good strategy your car is taking that's
one it's too easy for black to play this
I don't know just looks so so easy to
play with black okay well you
you had it here first 5V thinks it's
easier to play for black what do you
guys think
agreement I agree I agree I agree and we
definitely have to thank you so much for
coming on the show and congratulations
once again for beating Magnus Carlson
with the white pieces and picking up
those three points thank you thank you
yeah and uh we heard it there Fabiano
loving Black's position right now the
clock times as well have pretty much
leveled out at this point Wesley with
four minutes 40 against four minutes
from Hikaru Nakamura so into in terms of
the time in terms of the clock nothing
too much to worry about it feels like uh
Wesley a much with the advantage it
feels like he had a really healthy
position but just the last few moves
he's played a bit tentatively and uh
he's let that one slip and he hopes now
Judith of uh putting some pressure on I
can I think that I still like very much
that these three Bishop it it can give
some interesting mating uh ideas if the
queen can come G4 to E4 one day forcing
the Knight to be exchanged from F5
so I think there is little hope for
white still because if let's say Knight
E3 would be played in F takes E3 then
you cannot compare it to Bishop right
these three Bishop is very powerful on
the diagonal while the A7 Bishop can be
blocked very easily
yeah but there's one thing that really
worries me I mean Wesley now is has less
time on the clock than Hikaru and his
position is
I would say equal but you know more
uncomfortable it's just clock handling
or Wesley
too slow too slow he needs to speed up
right now Wesley he just needs to put a
move on the board like Queen G4 just
something active something to scare
Hikaru with and like you say Ivanka two
minutes now on one move that's too long
in an Armageddon game you just cannot
afford that type of luxury and okay
what's he doing it shows exactly what
kind of trouble he is in right that he
realized that it is something what he
has is not what he wanted
yeah and uh the saying goes long think
wrong think he spent a lot of time on
the clock there and a question mark from
the computer after this last move Bishop
C2 is that because it just gives up a
pawn in the center maybe black can get
greedy here and grab I think Wesley
wants to line up that battery you
mentioned Judith with uh Queen on D3
trying to crash through on H7 with a
nasty Checkmate but maybe it's just a
pipe dream if black is accurate it's
some bluffing
it is a bluff right because you're also
hitting the bishop on C2 yeah
oh and you can just see from the body
language between the two players Hikaru
he is primed for that win and he's ready
and look at that he pounces he grabs a
pawn but it does get a question mark
from the game review but the only reason
is because probably there was something
really much probably yeah maybe take it
with the bishop or something the other
night or with the other night was just
crushing but uh there we see Wesley's
position is so difficult to handle right
now that again a lot of moves here not
being approved off by the computer but
black support up and the key detail is
that Bishop takes Knight right now would
be met by a calm Bishop slide Bishop
back to E5 check the bishop would no
longer be attacked and black would
emerge a pawn up there we saw the
meaning behind all the notation that
we've been seeing the question marks the
exclamation marks and uh I think the
only conclusion is that black is a pawn
up with much more time on the clock
three minutes against two and a half now
this one is hikaru's I think yeah
Fabiano is spot on with his prediction
and I was thinking it was time to muddy
the waters and keep those opposite color
Bishops alive and whoa what is happening
here I mean can you not just well ghost
for activity Bishop working goes out and
from B3 the Knight will be jumping
against the V6 oh there's some three
ideas
Wow might as well go down fighting he
wants to emerge a piece up and I said
you're going to take back that white
Bishop maybe no longer Black's Bishop
also up for grabs is currently a knight
for two Pawns
black can grab another Pawn in the
process White's King will be weak but I
don't know how to evaluate that one
Judah well this was the only way of
playing it right there was no other way
this was the only option for white to
stay in the game and fight for a victory
okay it's in Balance suddenly Knight for
three pawns do you favor the piece of
the pawns here if you had to oh
definitely I would take luck yeah I mean
it's not just the three pawns that uh
what black has black also has a king to
Target and that's that's something extra
for their pawns and there you see giving
a check King moves to safety
I'm not sure necessarily the best black
had a safe way of playing it also to
exchange the queens and grab the B2 Pawn
now he is forcing the trade of Queens
but uh now cannot grab the pawns white
will still have three pawns remaining
still some winning chances in the end
game black though withdraw odds feels
like he should still be the favorite now
two minutes against two minutes clock
time's level but I think Wesley played
incredibly well and creating his uh
practical chances and now Rook F1
exchanging one Rook
do you think Hikaru needs to keep the
Queens on the board absolutely uh play
against the weak white king well by now
yes
but uh okay given a question mark
I mean now maybe it's time to utilize
that uh Rook on A1 and uh well Wesley
tucking the king
in the corner that's the safety first
don't forget the pawn on B7 attacked by
the White Queen
and uh okay he needs to move though
Hikaru he needs to speed up they'll have
a few more moves to make before they get
the beautiful one second increment but
White's Rook is coming in the white
Knight's gonna come in the black pawns
are not running I think that's key to
bring the Knight the bring the knight
from B3 to E4 F3 and Hikaru with uh well
he has to deal with the checkmating
threat that is coming his way and that's
why he slides his Rook over to protect
the g-pawn
I thought he was actually gonna miss it
he was kind of like gesturing somewhere
else and okay Wesley going for that
Queen trade will Hikari accept but look
how how he gains time right he offers
the queen exchange so he gains like 10
seconds because he Hikaru has to decide
should I exchange not you see on the
next move he does exchange yeah I've got
to say I don't like that decision so
much from Wesley it felt like White's
Knight if it joined the action could
have led to a nice attack in combination
with the Queens uh and the Rooks there
but okay now the end game the margins
are far tighter the margins are far
smaller because if the white pawns are
all traded off this one is going to be
interesting interesting decision to play
Rook E4
I thought he would be going rookie
rookie three that's what I thought
oh I don't like it from Wesley it feels
like that was the moment to switch gears
to go for the attack but Queens off the
board
suddenly weak pawns as well for white he
shattered his own Pawn structure he
needs to get that night into the game
well there we go it is in the game
tying down the black Rook now eyeing up
those black pawns on B7 and C6 that
white knight can come back into the
center at will first Wesley keeps his uh
I like the night on A5 a lot
I I like it too I think before
right C4 is a great move and then bring
the white king in and try to trade off
Rooks
he's going for those weak points Black's
pawns especially the Deep Pawn backward
and Hikaru sacrifices one of them but uh
if you take that black Pawn on D6
blackstroke comes down to E2 with a
check
and the players have uh passed move 41
so they are getting that one second
increment luxury
um second per move
and The Rook comes down rookie is really
very strong move going to A3
is to get that white king of
he needs to get that white king across
he needs to bring that Knight in
okay he's going for the pawns though it
is a race
how about the end game if all of the
queen side pawns disappear dude what
happens there well very good chance for
a draw
to remember if
all the pawns get traded off the board
it's just a draw
a rook and Knight after 100 of moves
exactly
and he's pushing his Pawn sikaru that
white has to bring the king in the
Rooker Knight alone will not be able to
win those black pawns on the queen side
still Anything could happen here 22
seconds and it's 14 seconds and Ticking
down for Wesley
and he has to find a good woman well
good sucker for the night and Hikaru
indecisive wow so much hesitation from
Hikaru Nakamura it's rare to see him
with this uh type of uh yeah hesitation
here in G5 okay but the White Knight is
coming round and winning pause oh he
didn't spot that one Wesley is gonna
pick up the B Pawn V3
to push B3 okay C2 and B3 yep same idea
but now it's uh I think it's lost
objectively yeah if the black g-pawn was
maybe back on its starting Square you
could have to build a fortress but
okay he's trying to ask for The Rook
trade here if Rooks come off the board
white will win with his remaining Pawn
now the king is coming again two seconds
with the repetition
okay can the white king advances
Wesley wins even the eve wow couldn't
take the pawn because King G6 Checkmate
oh wow hecar made a move with one second
left the pieces of flying all over the
board but white is totally winning and
Hikaru no handshake he resigns what does
he do sometimes I think he lost on time
Wesley takes the win oh
that went down to the wire
oh I have to catch my breath there after
those frantic moves at the end but uh
wow Wesley holding his nerves there to
steal the point from Hikaru
he's so close and uh well Wesley so
walks away with one and a half points
Hikaru starts off with one point and in
the meantime we do see another
Armageddon game kicking off and it's
between Nordic Abdul soturf and Anish
Gary
and uh this game started not long ago
Abdul satorov with the white pieces
starting with 10 minutes giri with black
starting with seven minutes a very
impressive first game by Anish Gary but
can he keep the speed up here two
minutes down on the clock and it looks
like the Catalan opening and uh still
early days in this one but Queens are
off the board
yeah it's interesting that they play a
kind of a solid game it seems but at the
same time it is very complicated I
believe because white has a very
powerful knight on E5 the great Bishop
fianchato Bishop on G2 while there is a
very
suspicious C4 poem which most likely can
be weak at some point but somehow the
pieces of black is strangely placed
Knight on A5 defending the B7 Pawn while
attacking putting pressure on C4 the
bishop on E8 is kind of tricky right
whether is it going to come to C6 one
day but now simplification is asked by
Anish yeah I really like this last move
really instructive white has weak pawns
on the queen side so more peace trades
will accentuate the weakness of those
weak white pawns and yeah I don't think
you really want to trade off this uh
Bishop because Black's root gets active
gains time against the White Knight and
even if the Rook has to slide back to C7
a bit later on everything's covered for
black uh yeah I really don't like this
development for Abdul sotorov it feels
like Gary is right at home in this type
of position and okay the bishop trade
looks like it's just happened there we
go I think this is a great help for uh
Anish F4
4 of course you have to stabilize your
knight on E5 nothing else beautiful
night that is the pride and joy of
White's position but Anish he's calmly
ready now to play B6 he's pushing his
Pawn to get out of the way of the eye
line of this bishop and yeah he's gonna
be hitting thinner this white Bishop
soon and winning chances starting to
dwindle probably C5 that's the only way
it is on the board to get rid of your
weaknesses
still we have to remember that nordeback
isn't a must-win situation this is
Armageddon after all and uh when we look
at the clock times we see that nordeback
does have a healthy one and a half
minute time Advantage now it's a
question that there should black go B5
or keep the tension and somehow try to
exchange the CNB Pawn in with some good
circumstances
yeah you want to get this these pawns
off the board but uh who's going to
trade on on Whose terms wow he slides
across some calculation needs to be done
but there is kind of a pin here we'll
see a trade of a set of Rooks
potentially and uh will Anish ensure
that he doesn't go upon down interesting
that the players are playing really fast
I must say kind of a little bit faster
than they should I think Abdul sartorov
is not spending enough time he started
out with seven minutes he still has six
minutes and 20 seconds and his position
is not that good that that he did not
spend uh practically any time all right
he started with 10 so he has spent a bit
of time sorry he started out then yeah
but uh I agree he's not spent enough
time to pose problems to the niche on
the board
but maybe the aim of the game is just to
play as quickly as possible and uh flag
Anish this there's no shame in flagging
your opponent everybody you're not going
to flag garnish in this position but he
still has 4 minutes and 38 seconds
problem is if it comes down to King
versus King it doesn't matter how few
seconds you have on the clock and I just
don't see how you're going to break this
black formation Black's Bishop nicely
protects this Pawn on B5 Black's only
weakness in the position and
you know unless somehow you can get your
king in maybe trade the Rooks and get
the white King Racing towards the queen
side uh I don't see any other plan
I mean I'm just thinking you don't need
to make a plan anything
um you can just simply improve your
pieces for the time being and then push
upon at the last minute
and I'm expecting black to play Rook C3
in the next move King fate I understand
wants to bring his King Rook C3 Rook A3
I like in the in the long term advancing
though G4 instantly met by G5 from
anishagiri he's really sensitive to
these little Pawn pushes these little
structural uh decision making uh I think
he's a genius there and I like it from
black he's locking down any advances
from right there on the king side but at
the same time you know it is a committal
move the Knight can actually step back
to D3
and say well you can't actually really
capture on F4 because then you'll have
to evaluate what's going to happen with
White's H Pawn
G5 I like very much I think it's a very
sharp move yeah
maybe King G3
to react with that activate the king and
not give up the
the tension from F4 not to exchange yeah
but Black's Rook is coming in as you
mentioned earlier yeah Rook C3 and then
you go Knight D3 okay he's found a
creative way to con kind of maintain the
tension here before aiming to recapture
on F1 I think we're all in agreement
black does not want to take that pawn uh
you don't want to isolate your own Pawn
on H6 so black jumps in uh
whoa and uh take a look at those clocks
you can see that a niche has actually
managed to whittle down that time
disadvantage and now it's it's level now
noribbeck has actually gone under wow
this is big I mean how are you gonna
flag someone when you don't when you
have less time than them yeah it's not
going to be easy but then again we were
almost writing off Wesley earlier with
less time difficult position and he
pulled it out the back he worked his
magic to win against Hikaru Nakamura and
uh also Anish Gary a bit like Fabiano
who was with us a bit earlier he's
improved enormously in terms of his
speed in terms of his Blitz and rapid
results recently so Abdul satorov of
course great speed player but Anish it's
his type of position solid strategic no
weaknesses and White's Knight Force to
retreat backwards no I think Knight C4
can be very powerful yeah do you start
with Knight C4 you could also maybe
flick this one first Force the white
breath back and then jump in with the
Black Knight it looks
also temptation is great there yeah
looks like a lot of choice for Anish
Gary maybe you don't want that in
Armageddon maybe that's the one Pitfall
to avoid you need easy obvious moves
instead of three or four clearly good
ones and uh Anish actually attacking the
a pawn forcing The Rook to all the night
to step back
oh
it's a
good move by Anish very simple to us
it's what you need
very impressive move he's played an
impressive game impressive match so far
if we take the classical game into
account as well and oh that white knight
was so nice and pretty on the E5 Square
now sitting on C1 and the niche oh not
approved by the computer this lasts me
if Ivanka no I mean I was surprised by
this because I felt Black's light Square
Bishop was such a great defensive piece
and I think it's still okay it's only
that he had a better move as well okay
because now if the exchange of Bishops
takes takes Rook D5 Rook B5 then Knight
D4 check
F3
oh wow
[Music]
Anish Gary how but it's okay winning
this position he's just uh found an
amazing move King takes Rook is met by a
knight check a night fork and the white
Rook will drop black will be winning a
piece
computer says finally it is winning for
black beautiful tactic and abdicator of
resigns oh great game by Anish I have to
say in both games in both the classical
and the Armageddon it just looked like
he was in full control absolutely
sharing his experience showing his class
and uh Abdus walking away with just one
point and a niche positively jumping for
joy walking away with one and a half
points and a victory in Armageddon
yeah beautiful display there of force
from Anish giri and it don't go into an
end game against him I think that is the
takeaway from that game uh just spotting
that tactic at the end in one second and
just playing it instantly he still had
three four minutes on his clock on each
very impressive stuff
and uh let's uh that means that all the
games have finished and uh let's take a
look at today's scores in the end
Fabiana karona defeated Magnus Carlson
in the classical game to walk away with
three points for alireza farouza it was
a bad day as he crashed out to a superb
good cash and cash picks up three points
sakuria
and Ari antari they drew their classical
encounter but it was Shakura who was
victorious in the Armageddon and the
same goes for a niche giri despite a
drawing a classical game he was simply
Supreme in the Armageddon and between
the a more American Showdown Wesley sir
and Hikaru Nakamura it was Wesley so
that emerged with those extra points and
Judith are you surprised by any of
today's results
oh well I can't really say that I'm so
surprised but of course the favorite was
uh kind of alireza in in that game with
uh what an opportunity what he missed
right the main surprise was for me that
Magnus lost and not only the fact that
he lost but the way he lost that was
more of a surprise yeah I totally agree
uh we have to shout out to go cash
taking down farusha as black but he did
write his luck as you mentioned there
Judith and yeah Magnus just out of shape
out of form missing simple tactics as
Fabiano mentioned there at the end
missing uh far too much by his high
standards it's uh not what we used to
but either way it's an exciting start to
the tournament and the armageddons were
very close all of them very well and uh
hard for it so it's been a promising
start to the tournament yeah those
armageddons really went to the wire I
mean I have to catch my breath after all
of those and let's have a look at the
standings and in the indeed we can see
with the early victories and the
classical portions we have Fabiana
karona and 17 year old gukash with three
points then we have Anish giri Wesley so
and Shakira mamijar for all winning in
the armageddon's portion to walk away
with one and a half points Hikaru
Nakamura in order back Abdus Turf and
Ariane both have all have one point
whereas Magnus Carlsen and alireza are
at the bottom of the table with no
points having lost in the classical
portion
and wow that is going to set us up very
nicely for the remainder of the
tournament and do we have pairings for
tomorrow
Maybe
I jumped the gun there no yes we do we
do have Wednesday's matchups and let's
have a look at what treats lie ahead for
us tomorrow Magnus Carlson will be the
one with the white pieces taking on
Wesley so Ari antari faces off against
nordebec abdusitor of gukash Hikaru
Nakamura that's going to be a big one
Anish giri plays Fabiana caruana whereas
alireza fuja plays a Shakura mamajarov
any matchups there that particularly
excites you
I think I would go very much for the two
the alireza and go cash game because I'm
very curious how it affected both of
them today's outcome yeah and for you
David yeah I'm looking forward to all of
them but uh Magnus against Wesley it
feels like it's early days but already
must win territory for Magnus he cannot
afford another show another performance
like today so I'm looking forward to
focusing on that one definitely and
it's been an exciting day and I'm
certainly looking forward to tomorrow's
matchups for me it would be all about
good cash against Hikaru I can't wait to
see how the youngsters challenge the old
God and uh well been a lot of actions so
far but it doesn't end today it will
continue tomorrow
and we will be here at the same time
same place 5 PM CET and we'll see you
then
foreign